i knew that she was gonna be that
victorian
i was called valedictorian out of this
school
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george george lopez oh my god
omg omg hi oh my god
you know you never consider yourself a
restaurateur
per se and um
chicano art paid the artist another
thing this one is the hibiscus one you
have the little mexi lager
i have the log what do you think good
huh this is uh this is my my favorite
beer i've been saying this for weeks now
i wish you didn't
only take one to [ __ ] get drunk you
could give me more
facts but you can't really after one you
won't remember telling me anything yeah
you're usually shutting it down after
one
but we have a few today sweet so
what are we supposed to do graham i'm
sorry i'm trying to get my head
into that box now we got another right i
get one today my grandfather used to
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna literally get
your head in the right track
[ __ ] i can't speak [ __ ]
english just to yell [ __ ]
on the right track that's amazing you
know right if he wants to say something
good he will say
about it you know but in english
get checked get on the right track
hey [ __ ] getting yelled at by the
[ __ ] mexican william conrad
the [ __ ] jake and the fat man and
that [ __ ] 64. i'm gonna turn 60
and he looked
like he could have been my dad only four
years separated us from right now from
the day he denounced himself he [ __ ]
denounced it
it's so great that he misses it by just
a little bit to make it difficult
a man that i said he wasn't afraid to
dive [ __ ] himself all the way to the man
you know you know nobody should ever say
whether they're afraid to die or not
until you get in the van because my
grandfather
thought that everybody was going to die
but him he'd be drunk and say
hey try to
get on that right track [ __ ]
the right so so you know um
i said on bobby lee's podcast that i
wish
that when we were kids and this is
everyone
because everybody gets told something by
a lot of people as a kid
and you you wish did that make sense to
you because you're looking to [ __ ] it up
there
like the answers are up there whether
the queen's gambit [ __ ] so
that's my memory um
so so um i forgot see
did you do that yeah that i wish like i
remember pop a video
yep like they would have the dudes
singing uh uh
did you hit a bug into my brain then it
[ __ ] pops and it says the dude's got
camel toe the second dancer in the back
is that what they said that's the
testicle during the you know west
westbury music fair you know uh when it
would just pop up information that you
didn't know which was pretty good
because as you're watching the video
yeah they would say you know guy
drinking the water
right and he'd go watch the guy coming
up behind you know yeah
so they would give you facts during the
video i wish our childhood could be like
that where
if somebody's yelling at you for
something a bubble would pop up and you
could read it
saying you know let this [ __ ] go because
this will [ __ ] with you for the rest of
your life and you're like okay thanks
papa bubble so that you know they don't
deflate you every day
well that would help because listen i
thought that like
let's see my grandfather worked a lot he
was always gone he was always tired when
he got home
and my grandmother worked and i felt
like the less time i spent with them
the better adult i was gonna be
honestly though do you think you kind of
raised yourself that way um as far as
that's concerned
is that the one question no i have
another question but i mean it could
you know you know probably that's a
pretty good question do i think that i
raised myself
um remember they used to call them
latchkey kids yeah
those are [ __ ] that they never
find over yeah those are the ones that
just disappeared you're dancing on the
video camera at a [ __ ]
bar store right there the [ __ ] world
i'll just park a lot of these disappears
ran from home and never made it back
there's a lot of there's thousands of
kids that
that go missing people that go missing
every day and around the world and don't
get serious on me but
you're not gonna leave me hanging out
there but no i'm serious man like when
you see like if you're
you know when you're a parent and a
child goes
goes missing like i don't think you have
you can't have a day's peace unless
you're involved
in it yeah of course well you know like
i thought he was in the park and like
that's what you said yesterday
it wasn't that you hear from the [ __ ]
back i told him to get on the right
track
so it's not i mean it's it's it's not
funny
uh but you know
you you can't you can't let kids do
what we did you know so much of growing
up now is about
you know some people say they have a kid
that's in their 20s and they go you know
when i was 22
i was already you know that should you
want to lose a kid forever
yeah tell them that yeah exactly that's
almost like yelling get on that right
track
yeah because your kid is like man
[ __ ] yeah once
like we all we all talk under our breath
when everybody gets yelled at everybody
does that yes
but when it starts to be like man [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that's when you lost
your kid because he ain't coming back
from that
if he says you know you're walking to
the car yeah i kind of know he's right
you know
i never said that but as long as you're
not just completely
profane all the way to the car and when
you start the car and you look at the
house like i can't wait to get the [ __ ]
out of this [ __ ]
then you remember you're 11 and you
don't know how to drive
[Laughter]
so do you think when especially when
you're in your teens when your
grandmother was mad at you or something
or gave you a bunch of [ __ ] or your
grandfather
were you kind of like i got this what
were you learning
there's two answers i want to give you
one
is they didn't really care
if i went to school or not like what kid
says hey you want to see my report card
they would be like
that like wow some parents are diligent
and if you have parents that are
diligent
god bless you because
i i think when you want a child
is different than when someone gets
pregnant
and you have to have a child like you
want a kid and maybe you think you know
you get married nobody does that
remember in the 50s [ __ ] you go to
bombay she'll be like in 11th grade
she's pregnant
she comes back what happened when i was
where i go
what is it what are you oh my god when i
go what are you
uh and you know she i went to go by i
went to bombay to visit my aunt
did you ever have bob babe so so
they would in the 50s they would send
them away crazy
if a girl got pregnant when she showed
yep they would send them
like i don't know where it was and where
there were special schools too
maya my lovely wife university yeah my
my lovely wife went to a special school
to win the hybrid award for
pregnant university yeah marcy
horvath [ __ ] horror
i knew that she was going to be the
victorian i
was called valedictorian out of this
school
[Laughter]
yeah she's the top of the [ __ ] around
the watch yeah she
and her dad from the fence chain-ling
fence get out of that [ __ ] track
yeah so what i i forgot my answer but
that was a pretty whatever i'm trying to
say i think is
could be important once they edit it
together but
but that we are you know that we didn't
when when somebody wants you it's
different than when somebody you just
have a child like i think in
in culture like like you know where
where money's tight you can't give that
kid
things that are not considered
you know luxuries [ __ ] a blanket
[ __ ] good shoes because you can't
couldn't go to school with [ __ ] up
shoes like i
i got my shoes at hughes market one time
this dude pulled my shoelace they were
brand new and they broke i better
[ __ ] brand new shoelaces oh no
and you know how they would run by an
entire shoe yeah snap
that's the way it
the coal from the uh seafood department
where the shoes were
you know across might have it hurt
the elasticity of my shoelaces i thought
you know putting on shoes in antarctica
right it made them a little brittle they
smelled like pranking
wearing [ __ ] prawns [ __ ] that jimmy
shoes
me um is there anything that that's
natural think of
that that your grandparents told you
like that was a profound statement that
you did remember
and help you through life like just a
great piece of advice is there anything
that came from them like that um
it's still not my question sorry you
know he my grandfather was about being a
man
of responsibility so a person of your
word but but what i'm trying to say is
when you know a child is left alone
or walks to school alone and comes back
alone and when he gets home there's not
anybody there um
a lot of things can can go wrong but
what happens with the inside of it
of a child at that age is you're always
afraid
so you're afraid that when you get home
nobody's there you're afraid when it
gets dark you're afraid
back then nobody called to say where you
were going so there's a fear
so then when you get home and you look
at your house and the car's not there
there's fear and then when you have a
place where you're just struggling to
make ends meeting you have a kid
and you're fighting and they see that
because everybody fought in front of the
kids
that you know i think
i i think that it affects
it has to affect the overall balance of
a child
if when he goes to school he struggles
and he goes home and no one's there
like that's tough for a kid to overcome
if somebody has a brother or sister or
an aunt that was home
you know like a lot of times you know we
had the mom's mom or the grandmother but
you know in the 70s late 60s in los
angeles there's only [ __ ] nine
mexicans so
if everybody spoke english except you
know the
i always smell like beans in the house
like the temperature 114
so i don't know what i'm saying but
you know sport that's what sports is
good for but but i don't think that
it doesn't kid any and you're not doing
them any favors
by having them spend so much time alone
or with
brothers and sisters and then you know
you know and and
and back then you would suffer in
silence where now you could go to the
teacher or tell your dad and get care
get therapy or real
real help yeah yeah can you imagine if i
told my grandfather you know every time
you tell me to get on the right track
you minimize me
he would have said [ __ ] run you over
with a [ __ ] car right now
i'll hit you with that once i get on the
right track up
so you almost have to listen to a kid
now where if we
said something to our parents like i
don't like when you tell me this it
makes me feel
like i'm you know stupid then they would
have probably said well then don't be
stupid then
yeah yeah that all hurt that all goes
pop up video
take that chair hit him over the small
of his back
but when we have kids now
even though that they're even though
that these kids
i don't think they get everything they
want a lot of times when you don't get
something that everybody else has you
feel
minimized and it shouldn't be about what
you haven't
and we don't have but music does that
rap music does it
videos do that instagram does it filters
do it
that's not the real person yeah and
what are we going to end up with in 20
years what are the values going to be of
the kids that are
13 14 even 20 right now
that's why when robots take over they'll
be better because
humans won't be able to do [ __ ] for
themselves yeah yeah
and you want somebody to show up at
seven o'clock in the morning there's
nobody that's growing up right now
that's gonna be there at seven o'clock
in the morning so you might as well have
[ __ ] harvey right here
a [ __ ] tripod show up with [ __ ]
felipe right there and both of them
can carry this thing out right you're
waiting for two kids who are millennials
right now to come and work
so yeah you know zoom and this last year
of you know of losing people and people
who didn't
believe that that was true or
think differently about being vaccinated
but
these flus have come throughout the
years
not new not being prepared for it is new
but the idea of the flu is not new and
it's almost 600 000 people that have
been lost it's crazy and people refuse
to be vaccinated vaccinate people refuse
to be vaccinated or refuse
to believe that the election was real
[ __ ] wwe crowned the new champion
nobody [ __ ] double guessing that
but the [ __ ] president they're out
there [ __ ]
stuffing back [ __ ] the night
hawk i don't watch [ __ ] wrestling
with a [ __ ] day with a [ __ ]
oh the principal man i don't [ __ ]
know their names
how
the wings and jumps out of the water the
third buckle
uh so so the turnbuckle yeah i don't
know what that was
that's awesome how was that man pretty
good i'm not sure what the [ __ ] it was
that was just one answer so i'm saying
that
i don't think the kids have the
fortitude because that has to be put in
you through through something tough
like iron metal metal one
how much we [ __ ] pay attention right
now you talk to a [ __ ] kid that
[ __ ] looking at his phone
don't [ __ ] try to talk jeremy you
know i won't be alive in a year he's
like this
hang on i don't think i'll be here
we go to the us festival there's [ __ ]
675 000 people
and a little skinny [ __ ] and a
red look like jiminy cricket
right like i got that [ __ ] uh
mr bob and he came pranking like jack in
the box
yeah without the head this guy's in a
red suit he walks up to the microphone
he goes
you're right for meadows
and everybody knows what he's saying
yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] speakers they're saying they had
a [ __ ] talent over their shoulder hey
you heard what he said out of here he
said he tell him pass it down
he says that you want metal you got it
pass it down
it's a little quiet right beatles played
shea stadium with the speakers from the
[ __ ] met
game oh my god that's crazy to me
they could understand a word they're
saying right no one could say they
couldn't hear themselves
tell you something fly ball the lip
center
[Laughter]
lenny used to change the words
you gotta be having you gotta check out
that quiet rap video he comes from
there yeah pal driver bible says that i
never never mind
well done how about that's what i'm this
what this whole last
[ __ ] 45 minutes have been about
like that so i think you know
maya's 25 and i had a conversation with
anne about
some things that that she would like her
to do but she wants me to tell her
so why does she be thinking do you know
they hold more weight
yeah they're more serious but listen
have you ever wanted to get some real
information that was serious you didn't
want it for me so that's how
times have dipped you're right i'm the
one giving you bad information i've
never had the joke that
when somebody dies mexicans always laugh
they're like hey yeah hey man remember
that dude that i worked for
that was man he died and you're just
like oh
and you're chuckling what is that on the
death certificate that said he wasn't on
the right track
but um i had a cousin that got hit by a
[ __ ] train and you're like how the
[ __ ] you hit by a train but
you see it coming and if you can't hear
it there's a train away
no it's not you know you leave just from
the knee down yeah
you can feel it coming and the dude saw
the leg
on the train and he said sir i have to
stay on until the train comes to a stop
he didn't know that that there wasn't
from the knee above
he thought he was talking to a person
he's talking to the leg that's trapped
in the he's talking to the [ __ ]
in the arm grip oh god of the of the
train sir please be seated the train's
gonna come
there's nothing connected to them from
those pants down from the knee down
where was it where what where'd that
happen right outside of no it happened
uh
if i if i say though they'll know who
they is but i'll just say right out of
santa fe springs i don't know there you
go that time we took the train it took
[ __ ] a day and i had to get to san
diego yeah we thought it was the
greatest idea ever
and then we forgot about the 40 stops
and a couple delays that was awesome
i felt like i was a teenager start stop
start stop
i don't know where you think you're
going stop
um one time when i was uh
uh i saw that one time when i was i'd
eaten some chilaquiles that my
grandmother had made it was a friday one
of my favorites
ever and then arnold comes over
we're still in high school and he says
hey let's go to the dentist i said no
man i'm in because i already i
already ate and i didn't think i was
going anywhere yeah
so school dance so i had to ate all
these chilaquiles of chili
if you don't know it's a wonderful dish
you want to say what it is yeah
it's like it's like a breakfast today
but it's chopped up eggs or meat
and every sauce you can think of over
chips which is ridiculously good
corn chips and bread yeah so i had a lot
of those
then we went to san fernando park and we
drank schnitz small liquor the bowl
look out for the bowl and then
ernie was driving on the way back to the
high school we hit the road it was going
like this and i was like
inside i was like oh my god man i think
i'm on
so in line to get into the dance i just
you know very casually back then
you just went projectiled
oh beautiful you know like an old batman
comic book where they throw the fire out
of the mouth
like like like it goes like you know no
oh my god and it's out
and then this girl they're going hey
this girl wants to dance with with me
like i
you know harry chunk i have another
couple years yeah so we're dancing
in the middle of san fernando high right
by the where they tip off for basketball
i look down
and my right shoe has [ __ ] chill
aquilas oh
from outside i thought it was a rose a
wedding
well well uh we are going to have uh vic
aguilar on
rick dragular is the guy that um
was a 22-year police officer with the
los angeles police department whenever i
had an issue because a lot of times
i think most times people don't have
access to somebody who's actually going
to get
something done so i thought he would be
a good guest to answer questions
because maybe on topic that
you know all i watch is youtube and
there's a phenomena of
why they say a phenomena because a lot
okay that's all you gotta say while you
say a lot be thought about the word
phenomenon
so so of a lot of guys who
who get cars and and dress them up like
undercover police cars or drive a black
and white
if you want to look at youtube uh
there's all kinds of instances of it and
pull
people over yeah and ask for their id
follow people
back in the day maybe a cop would pull
some chick over when i was in high
school
judy like i pulled over by some cop and
the cop asked for a number just like man
yeah yeah already you don't like them i
mean you kind of they're already
there to be peace officers but when
you're trying to get a piece you're like
peace out i guess i'm [ __ ] trying to
draw my girlfriend i need something
different okay why don't you go
and chock tires and see how long they've
been there's like come over here go get
your own name
yeah i'll put my guy right there leave a
chocolate you come and see that
you know to stay away sir a peace
officer
i was tonight uh yeah we're gonna do
some voicemails and then we're gonna do
actually news before that but before
that even uh
we have this little thing we'd like to
start with a one question
maybe if you're into it yeah
so do you do you want to start it would
you like me to throw one at you what do
you want to do uh
i'll i'll go i won't last time but i'll
ask you what go ahead all right here's
my question and i know and uh
it's not the people that you're best
friends with but we all know that you
know a lot of
celebrities in hollywood or all over the
world i'm just asking you i would think
that most people want to know
that's a real question is some [ __ ]
it's a real question i told you to ask
before we go no no no this is real
i'll take that sign right there
who of all the celebrities and people
that you've met
is there anybody who who you were
actually um
who affected you the most when meeting
him not like after knowing him but when
meeting him what who affected you the
most that you've met
who do you think it is well i well
obviously
to me and and i'm thinking maybe elton
john
those two are my top but i'd love to
know
okay there's stories there because in
the in san fernando there was a
buddhist monastery and if anybody looks
for things to
believe in there's always signs around
your whole life
you know something that you believe in
doesn't just appear you see it and then
you see it again maybe
you're not even um aware that it's
something you might be interested in and
i think that's why subliminal messaging
and
you know things that they put in movies
now where you see that they put you know
yeah go get a snack
fat ass get a [ __ ] cake in there yeah
just flash it you're like did anybody
else see cake um
but there was buddhist in san fernando
as a monastery that my grandmother
of course they were uh harry krishnas
and that every time you saw them but
they weren't and then when i moved to
you know another part of los angeles
germany there was a monastery there and
then a couple other places where i live
now but in
2009 i think i was in a really
dark place self-destructive place i've
always been a little self-destructive
but
it's what kind of it's what's kind of
i wouldn't say it kept me alive because
that's almost delta but but there is a
little bit of
self-destruction in my life for in order
for me to feel like
i am achieving more than someone else
like i didn't have it easy but then also
i like to go have a good time
and i was a little bit out there
dangerous not to anyone else to myself
which is even i think more dangerous
you hit somebody fight somebody with a
car they're going to feel it not me
i'm going to take off so so
but in those things you always have to
feel like an underdog
in order to feel like you really want
because nobody thinks we're going to win
you too nobody anybody's going to win
anybody's going to be successful so
when you get victories you i don't even
know if you really
celebrate those things like when tiger
woods won that he wouldn't or kobe won
a championship people would look at the
ring once and then try to go get the
next one which i think is a
little bit more um
of those talents than a person where you
know that everybody where you come from
isn't expecting you to do much with your
life
that is motivation enough i don't think
it's motivation enough today
because they're always told that they
can do whatever they want
and so yeah for for me
was i surprised yes but did i expect it
no
but was it a total surprise absolutely
and then that is what makes it
makes me very genuine i think when
people see me i had times when i wasn't
but i was sick remember but i think now
when you hang out with me i'm always
very nice to people very generous to
people
but yeah so dalai lama i would say yes
because it changed my heart
yeah but i mean elton john's singing
me happy birthday after
those songs meaning so much to me
i think is um it might be it that was
huge yeah i mean i was such a huge
fan i would sing those songs to myself
and then bernie topping at the
two years ago that you know i took some
friends and
he walked in and you know he's doing
like oh my god man there's a bernie
topping right there so i i was like
i told one of the ticket people i said
hey i think you could introduce me to
bernie i
got to drop these tickets out but yeah
and then when i went back in he saw me
and he goes
george bernie i was like oh hi
bernie and then he said sir elton told
me you were coming to the show tonight
so that's what i'm going to put on my
channel yeah right that's going to be
the next tattoo is going to be george
bernie
sir elton told me you were coming to the
show how perfect right here on my chest
i haven't figured out the fun yet but
that's what it's going to be and that
and that
meant a lot because elton john was very
kind always very kind to me and
respectful
and we would congratulate him on his you
know stays on residencies and we'd see
him on tour but
uh bernie thompson doing that yeah
because although and you know you don't
have the time to say that all those
words
you wrote you know kind of meant
something
okay it was almost like something you
could feel yeah
not just sing but you could feel it and
and and that
yeah anybody like outside of those two
though
you think
i i think maybe i think maybe bruce
springsteen
i think because we weren't friends in
high school and that one guy was dave
wilcox and he had born to run and we
before we went to
baseball practice and we were a year
older he would play board and run and
we're like what's up
yeah what's that you take it off and
then i went to go see him in the river
in 1981 and then
he played we're in the last row and he
played three hours plus and
and just i mean can you imagine that
a guy like that to
anybody in l.a that was like the last
night's and i'm i'm looking for things
to connect to that aren't
family related yeah and here i was so
against
that music and then once i had a chance
to see this guy
and his motivation and clarence clemons
and the whole band all except that they
were
you know like a unit like a family yeah
and that from that time forward that
that music
means so much to me now and then when he
was in broadway
i saw the show a couple times and you
know went to see him after and
he was very cool so so that that helps
yeah and if you didn't think you could
like a more a dui that could be like us
so no but that i think that that was
meant a lot because i mean he through
his
career and then you're almost like a
contemporary not a contemporary but
really almost almost like the same age
yeah and then you just
are there with this guy backstage and
his wife was patty was very great as
well
awesome beautiful all right well let's
do some news
you know for a little news ready for my
one question oh wait i have a question
yeah or your
question for me how how are you
medically
how's your health ah great question
thanks for asking
because you know i think it's uh helpful
to people did you did you
well no how's your health it's good how
am i going to answer your
[ __ ] answer then ask the question let
him answer it
i was going to answer the question for
you he's delicious right now
i'm delicious that's a great so how was
your health i'm good i
i had a scare as you know a year and a
half ago
uh i had a uh pulmonary embolism and
went in hacking and they they found a
clot in my lungs so strong
scary so okay so we travel a lot yeah
um and then you're hacking a lot and
you're going there were you hacking
blood
no i was i we had you and i had gone to
hawaii
and i came back and i was coughing and i
thought it was something i caught or
something i couldn't stop coughing i
thought i had bronchitis
so i went to the doctor and they and my
wife had just told me
a co-worker of hers did not go to the
doctor he felt like he had pneumonia he
died before he went to the doctor wow so
she said if you get a chance to take an
x-ray or something take the x-ray don't
just
take antibiotics that's a little bit of
a big time
it's kind of a little bit of a well it's
unfortunate for the dude but it's kind
of a sign
yeah that's a big because if that hadn't
happened i'm not sure you you know
you're
i would not have 100 not if that's not
my style they would have said you want
some antibiotics yes
see you later and it's more it was more
serious than that yeah so they took an
x-ray and they said we got uh
good news and bad news uh good news is
you don't have bronchitis bad news is
you have a
blood clot in your lungs so you need to
get to the hospital right away so it was
a scary and they found out that i also
had an enlarged aorta
an aortic aneurysm as they said which is
not great that's not good
no so there's two things that that were
kind of a big deal all of a sudden
and so uh just kind of went on how did
you feel how did you feel with it
because
those things my grandfather died of a
blood clot yeah that got loose he had a
angioplasty and the doctor said to him
not to walk
a lot of people either don't go to the
doctor or don't
take the advice of the doctor yeah
that's the thing and he did not
because he thought it made him feel like
less of a man and he [ __ ] himself before
he got to the van
ah man get on that right track
but but for you yet but for you yes it's
serious yeah
listen i was i was sick and i got better
yeah but when you think everything's
going along
great yeah i had no idea i had no idea i
had an issue and then all of a sudden
they said go to the emergency room and
you tell them what you got and they'll
put you in the front of the line
kind of thing like you get in there like
now and
you know spend a night in hospital and
they watch me and i went to a million
doctor's appointments after that and put
me on blood thinners the whole nine
and uh i was a year and a half later
they keep checking me up i'm the same
and uh the pulmonary embolism is gone
because i
i had another scare when we were about
to go on the road i said hey i'm hacking
again so i gotta hang back and take more
tests and like whatever whatever you
gotta do so
went there they checked it out so they
did give me another um scan
a ct scan and it was negative so i had
nothing there
so which is maybe the worst thing you
can have on fly
yeah that's oh 100 yeah yeah
it'll it'll bounce around and get you
and that's what they were thinking and
my problem was they never figured it out
they were thinking it's because i
traveled a lot and i didn't get moved my
legs enough
kind of thing you know what i mean so
when you're on a flight but you've been
a healthy dude you play football
and you work out all the time yeah
incredibly strong i was great
great shape you know when i got in there
like hey your vitals are fantastic that
kind of thing and my
my pulse was like 56 or something like
that so anybody who's listening
who never take your health for granted
or never take your body trying to tell
you
something for granted because your car
will tell you it needs oil needs water
red light goes on all
signs are warning signs that your body
tells you
and if you don't uh heed the warning
then sometimes the warning signs go away
yeah and then it goes into something
deeper so in the beginning when you
start to feel pain
it's something that's still manageable
but then if it goes away
then it's going to come back yeah and
it's
and it's not an age thing i mean it is
and it isn't i mean i
i have i in my 50s and in my early 50s
of the six guys i hung out with high
school two of them passed away one of
them had a
massive heart attack and i had this so
four of the six have had some
serious health issues in our early 50s
so i don't know if it's whatever we
drank back then but i mean it you got to
check it out we all felt healthy listen
jeffrey dahmer didn't have
a [ __ ] the number of people that died
around him like you
i know exactly all those dudes you went
to high school with they've been
knocking at the door
and my cousin here because he was all
remember all that time that
all those guys that you were and it
wasn't any women was it
no no it was one that that her doctor
i will say her name but also
second opinion on health because
remember she was doing okay and the
doctor said oh we'll give you a little
and it
didn't work on her but she was fine
without
some radiation yeah yeah yeah it was it
was
what had happened uh had a brain
uh tumor they radiated it out
and they operated and got it all out and
they said well just to be sure
we're gonna give you chemo killed her
man she was fi i mean fine fine
like she was absolutely okay i supposed
to be on the [ __ ] show
looking over there oh he's talking to
the audience [ __ ] griffin
[ __ ] right here right here
talking to the back of the room talking
over there
what do you think about that
yeah unfortunately that was what
happened with that that was uh
that was uh but my health is great
thanks for asking but yeah right now but
you gotta
i gotta check it out all the time now
i'm on the radar you know what they call
me you know health
you know canada's very different but you
know a lot of things that
are wrong with this well with any
civilization is you know there's a lot
of people out there that are very sick
and there was really no place for them
to go and that's unfortunate
because i saw a lady waiting for the bus
that was so
swollen even if i wanted to give her a
ride i don't think she'd fit in the car
so oh my god you know that's that's what
i'm saying
it hurt me to see her it hurt me to see
her
and homeless and not in good health so
before they had free clinics and now you
can't do that there's not so much of
that but
if there's one thing i would wish that
it would be that there was better
um medical treatment for
people who are not well or mentally ill
how about this
a dog gets loose in the neighborhood and
everybody looks for it they put it on
neighbor next door
they put it on all the apps they find it
they celebrate it some dude is walking
around your house
trying to steal your mail that dude's
not mentally aware
and nobody says [ __ ] about that but a
dog running around
they pick him up and get him treatment
yeah but you know
some do it from trinidad tobago yeah
yeah he's on his own he's crying out by
stealing people's mail and
he he goes to jail and there's no gun go
fund me for him
there's a gofundme for every dog i don't
know tobago all right what else
that's good i'm glad i'm glad you're at
least thank you very much i appreciate
it
but also when i asked you you know when
i asked you
you know hey maybe you should hang back
you said you said no
yeah well i mean it's not like i want to
i want to just
you know yeah i said it wouldn't be
healthy for you to
fly but you considered
yeah i mean i i'm not running the red
light traditional like you know like
that
yeah i mean but it's not so crazy where
i'm at right now where before like if
i wasn't treated for this i would have
been in trouble but i know now it's i
mean i think i'm i think i'm okay to
live
and do my thing you know run around work
out
that is that all that helps that's the
thing anything that's that's hereditary
well see at first no
it is hereditary uh uh mary lou my
mother has
an enlarged aorta as well so i don't
know i'm assuming that's hereditary but
they found that out in the last couple
years as well do you think that's why
our titties are a little bit bigger
because yeah
there's more blood there's a little bit
i can't believe i just said that about
my mom
let me tell you have family members
listening i'm not into that 91 year old
but if i was
i would send a rehab van straight over
to our house hold up
the old rehab patch
all right news from twitter that trump
tobago
trumango it's a great vacation spot all
right
all right let's move on to the next time
how much time was that we've been we're
kind of rolling right there
we went 38 already a lot of [ __ ] in
the world hey man
well people got their [ __ ] together we
wouldn't have another taco bell
this first uh story in a long time
scifi.com
it's a that's a news agency that's all
the dudes that jack up and get mecca on
their keyboard
they do everything they do everything
with us they eat with their hands jack
off and play
all their games with the same hand
without watching them
and then they're typing in the computer
they'll wash their hands but once a year
they're not going to see a woman's
stethoscope so they'd be you know
they definitely won't touch them so no
big deal jacking off playing a game at
the same time
a little head piece like that that's not
something
someone's getting a little rough you
could have killed that guy
i'm glad listen i didn't have a lot of
friends but i'm glad that i never turned
well the gamers make a lot of money but
if you're good at it but you got to be
there
they went in there and shot like five
people yeah how about that that now
that's
while they're on they're here okay
somebody want to turn that down
no they have no idea when and came back
in
how crazy is that i think well don't
worry pick him up in the parking lot and
take him
to pause and pause p-a-u-s-e would you
say that's a reason that a lot of people
are doing mass shootings is because of
games i can't say that that's
no you know things have i think it's
more mental illness yeah i think such as
well
which is a big big issue yeah because
if you're living your life correct
that somebody who's mentally ill
you know is dangerous out there and they
should be
getting some help yeah when uh ernie
that time there was a guy that was a
homeless guy in san fernando and the guy
says you got any spare change and i said
oh sorry i can't help you and then
ernie says let you [ __ ] bomb once you
get a job you know piece of [ __ ]
and that guy's like what and he goes you
heard me and the guy had an ice pick
backwards like this in his hand and you
know
so here's a guy showing not showing any
respect and i said no no where it's cool
and then when the guy walked away he
showed the ice pick and i said hey man
that dude
he could have taken him out imagine that
so
there's people out there that are not
well
well the thing is they can't find a
place to to and there's nowhere to yeah
get help what about the sports are oh no
they tore it down to the soccer field
what about um
huh here we go the merv griffin theater
at five stars
throw them in there some
shows up there you know people used to
stay in the theater all day why don't
they just do that
yeah remember that remember though oh
pussycat
[Laughter]
when i was 18 years old yeah go on the
day of my 18th birthday
here's my value as a young person no
wonder i can't connect with any other
individual in my life that doesn't have
a penis
the on the on my 18th birthday april
23rd
1979 me and the guys from my baseball
team went to go see
deep throat and the devil and miss jones
how about that
for a bonding experience some lady that
takes it off
pelosi
[Laughter]
how does she have time to do that and
raise five kids yeah
then you realize how uncomfortable it is
to be watching sex things right next to
your buddies
well you're just past puberty that's
unfortunate that was no big deal
well all right first story guy steals 21
million dollars of lunar rocks to have
sex on the moon
that's right scifi.com exactly the kind
of story you
think they would come up with these guys
perfect we don't know how we missed this
story but a few years ago a nasa intern
was convicted of moon rock theft
specifically he stole moon rock so he
could have sex with his girlfriend
on them and who was it
boss aldrin jr yeah that's right
huh yeah our song the bird oh
god what did they call it they call it
the lunar module both
both dicks or their face they can't see
anything
just balls from far away couple of moves
the lunar module is coming in one huge
load
oh god for her one
small step for bankruptcy
you feel the crater that well you know
what that that's
that's awful i get i guess people
[ __ ] like bunny costumes i don't know
it you know back in my day
you couldn't cover true can you cover
yourself but you know women wanted a
nice mattress maybe a water bed but not
rocks listen but the story is so great
how loose does a girl have to be that
she'll [ __ ] you on some rocks
yo [ __ ] everybody seriously that is such
a great story though
[ __ ] you in the middle of that [ __ ]
sahara desert
i can't get wet unless i'm surrounded by
rocks oh god
imagine saying that your girlfriend hey
i stole these moon rocks let's have sex
on the moon tonight ha ha get it like
let's get stoned and have sex on
moonroof what's that guy's name he's not
i'm sure his name is thad roberts
who was in love with his girlfriend of
three weeks
decided to show her a grand romantic
gesture by stealing moon rocks so they
could jam the rocks
under their motel room mattress and have
sex on the moon
because robert's interned at nasa he
didn't have blame it on women
satisfying with some flowers or a nice
dinner that he's like hey you want to
steal some rocks from work
let's [ __ ] on the moon here i could lose
my job oh yeah well
oh my god that's just awesome why don't
you just
doused her in some [ __ ] ladder
through a ladder of fire hey now we're
[ __ ] on the sun
she's trying to piss to turn herself out
[Laughter]
yeah they sent him to federal prison for
seven and a half years for that little
well good they'll be here for the
[ __ ] mattresses over there are
[ __ ] hard as a rock i'm sure
you'll be [ __ ] shooting loads all
night at home i feel like i'm back on
the moon got out there
you should get the farmer's almanac to
know which which night the moon is
closer
oh god increase your penetration
wow man that's there's some crazy ass
people out there yeah that's uh
that's a good one if i had a rock in my
shoe i'd stop [ __ ] yeah
it's a funny story so he went to jail
seven years federal prison so but i mean
he did it probably just to [ __ ] around
got these rocks away but there's a lot
of money in rocks like what
they must be priceless they didn't they
uh it doesn't price on that almost like
a garage sale you're like
hey how about this one is that one oh
yeah that's from saturn no that wasn't
that one
i don't know twelve dollars how about
this one hey that's what that's what
mars
put that one back yeah right you can't
take that one that's a mars one
yeah crazy that's it yeah moving on
walter cronkite the worst
[ __ ] announcement i know exactly and
that's all there is
i'm sure you call the show right man
[ __ ] walter cronkite's on the phone
together he calls it he's alright man
you read the news trying to stutter all
those old dudes are all dead
yeah poor guy this is a uh
trusted newscaster in the world right
there's no such thing as that anymore
and now it's some if you're with one of
the majors right now they're blended
chick on channel two from four to seven
in the morning
all right blended chick all right this
one from my favorite irishtimes.com
irish times god bless america uh in
ireland
man evicted my man richard coogler used
to say i'll give her the shelley
we'd be in junior high and he would i
don't even know how he sounds like they
might be german
so he would be like remember to grab her
but we're walking down in junior high in
the seat building
grab her butt it's seventh grade this
has been great
and then he would walk over and go i'm
gonna give her a shoulder i didn't know
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] lady was
yeah it's the old uh i'm sure give it to
her
yeah he wasn't that guy can you express
you lately i i
looked it up and there's all kind of
[ __ ] in there i can't do that more than
haggis
i guess that was the worst stuff ever
but i did try it that's about that time
we got
all also in scotland yeah that was great
and then i try to i always try to soak
my hangovers away
but came out [ __ ] my water looked like
[ __ ] ghost lager
i was like i gotta get out of this water
they got flakes about
either either i'm a drinking ghost lager
or big daddy
had a little almond joy break up during
re-entry into the earth's atmosphere
who's big daddy
that's it's too funny all right it's
funnier than you're laughing like you're
trying to hold yourself together
meanwhile i know i'm trying to make it
right
i'm drinking my lager oh is that right
this is my locker it's my favorite oh
that's
something that's mine but i really the
color will play
about that day only when they didn't
shine i thought
starting to suspect something how
about when you got up in the in your in
the morning and you're like what are you
doing here
in the room remember you're in the room
and we're not after we just got
destroyed the night and we
were supposed to go back and i think
you're supposed to make an appearance or
something like that
and that's when we we were singing
no no that wasn't no remember we just uh
uh it was because the wind delay oh
in scotland yeah yeah yeah and we just
got just
we're playing in the dunhill cup and the
wind was so strong
it was blowing a professional golf bag
over and over again
and those things are at least 80 pounds
yeah
huge and we didn't play that day and i
think that's how i got uninvited because
remember i thought i was in the lobby
and i was in my room yeah i was always
talking what are you doing here and
you're like i'm in your room i was
i was waiting for you to bring me the
key and i was already in my room yeah
yeah
we were we were toasting and then you
could hear uh don felder singing hotel
california we were walking past we were
so drunk and we were holding each other
up
walking back to the hotel and we here
right next to us
don's playing hotel california literally
playing it
one of the members who wrote the song
it's trying a place that
has celebrated drinking for so many
years would remove me because of my
antics
i can't imagine but how about i get it
you're saying some i always get thrown
i've been thrown out of some of the best
places in the world
all right irish time speaking of dragon
what what's okay what's with the most
posh pleasure
you think you've been either uninvited
from or kicked out of
the most posh places catholic school in
the third grade no
[Laughter]
do you know that when i was in nobody
knows this
a man i don't know where baby there's a
boy named louie adams man
and guido's man either over the hill man
and gooey
just he just dreamed of sex i'd never
ever been over a man to smell or
permeate
through his high karate uh so so
um hi karate from elvis
uh that's awesome man the minute we
start making money in this thing i'm
gonna start letting the
other stories come back okay cool all
right well hang on i'll give you a final
deal all right what's that one irish
type but but
okay irish time this you think this
would be about drinking but it's not man
evicted tenants for growing cannabis
then set up own grow house for himself
so that's what everybody did yeah so he
shut up shut okay the man had burned 33
cannabis plants
where did this happen this was
in uh europe
all right good thanks for narrowing it
down okay
thanks for hey you know what as you're
saying that i can almost no this is not
gonna see the guy right now this isn't
yeah what i was thinking man i wasn't
ready for that one because i'm looking
at the things that it says he
don't [ __ ] read a headline with it
you're leaving me in the dark oil
man offered five thousand [ __ ] jacket
on
pounds to grill chris gave me this
jacket
destroyer tour 1977 oh that's funny okay
yeah this is uh in
our glass charleville county
in cork there you go in cork ireland
have we been to cork
uh yes we went through cork i don't
remember what it was like but i remember
it was on the itinerary
that's all i could see yeah hey uh
what was your favorite place in ireland
if you remember the last trip that
castle we stayed at
yeah that was really that was in
scotland that what that wasn't scott
which was in ireland where were we
playing ireland
belly button i can't remember oh the one
we stayed by the water i think that was
yeah yeah that was uh kinsale was
amazing
my niece's middle name and uh the
greatest place in ireland that's your
niece's middle name
what's her name molly kinsale ryderman
all right
she got three names [ __ ] serial
killers yeah exactly
is everybody missing a wallet or a purse
or a cat yeah
she's not it's not good with animals or
something
i'm very successful so uh a man who
evicted tenants for his
property after he found out that they
had set up cannabis grow house
only to then take over the operation
himself has received a two-year
suspended sentence
so he was running on an apartment
building yep
and then he started to grow cannabis
marijuana whatever you want to call it
and he and as his uh business started to
thrive he started throw tenants out
yeah exactly so he kicked him out
and and they were cannabis growers like
it was the whole deal that they
all they got him into it and they yeah
yeah he threw him out and then he became
the guy
so they know what that's when he [ __ ]
broke up they didn't talk for 25 years
[Laughter]
i was like really did you see my face
but but um
is i don't know the situation of
marijuana in europe
yeah uh i don't see they discovered 23
mature cannabis plants with a strawberry
they were like this one come in
that's right we were expecting you yeah
they all had hair under their arms
they did uh that eighteen thousand
pounds
money pounds in the container uh
i'm trying to think on five thousand
pounds given a total value of a seizure
of 23
000 pounds relatively dollars so this
guy overtook the whole operation and
took it for himself
how about that but i think he's almost
like um
one of those um
i can't see uh one of the guys that
makes it early
who made it early and then somebody else
came um
is it like an actor or something i don't
know maybe but but
you know i don't believe that canon when
we went was there places to get it
i don't remember in ireland i i the only
place [ __ ] drunk you're looking for
one of those places you're looking for
we're drinking i mean to get a paint
mask oh man i don't i don't think that
maybe in europe around the world i'm not
sure what their
views are on marijuana yeah but
um they seem to be perfectly happy with
just over being overserved yeah exactly
right
and none of them drive either yeah
that's big
except the dude from t-rex they have hit
the wall yeah he didn't like come on
yeah that was rough that was right but
but in amsterdam they said the only
people who were stoned were
people from london or people from the
united states like the people
the people who lived there they just
didn't do that stuff so brian and i went
to amsterdam a few years ago and i told
him we were going to be high from 10 in
the morning
till 10 at night and then we went over
there and we went to a place and we had
a latte
it smoked a big joint got [ __ ] up oh
my god drank a diet coke went to another
bar went bar hopping
and we went into one place and we looked
around and looked up and had pictures of
you know dudes and we're like
there's a gay cannabis club bar
in amsterdam and he said you want to
leave but i said no
and i said we can't leave it's rude so
we yeah we didn't so we blew everyone in
there
a great time and then we got something
to smoke
and then we stayed in there yeah but
then we went shopping
when we were high and i found this
jacket in the window and i said
man that thing is gideon man so i walked
in there
and i said uh i didn't notice that
everybody in there was a woman and then
i said
hey you happen to have this in my size
and what did you say because sir this is
a store for women
i lost my [ __ ] because i was really
stoned at that point so
i almost had to crawl out of that place
i was laughing so hard oh my god we were
laughing so i realized it was a woman's
story yeah that's hilarious
all right move from the nice jacket a
little parka orange yeah
it works you just zipped up the wrong
side that's okay
[Laughter]
we were all [ __ ] up in the foot
massage and then we got the oh
you got
and those the girls from america were
like is there any peanut sauce and then
you're just like
[ __ ] waiter was like you don't want
to just go back in the [ __ ] kitchen
and
[ __ ] pick something out you can eat
yeah right everything they ordered they
asked is there pizzas or this does this
touch is that that is a scallop in it
the biggest pains in the ass and that
was my favorite place in the world
amsterdam and not because i i like
marijuana so much
but just because the vibe was crazy and
then in the middle
of the rapid transit like a tram in the
middle of the city
you have families riding a bike nobody
wearing a helmet and nobody gets hit
yeah because they grow up in that
culture but not here because
we have to get everywhere fast and we're
late yeah
yeah and you have to you know you clip a
kid you just keep going
that well that's something we noticed
too it it if you're jumping in that
bike traffic in amsterdam that's a
panicking you're sick that's
an american yeah but we're there they're
very yeah they're
completely efficient i mean what about
when we were at the anza hotel and
somebody dropped a plate
and not here like in america nobody
clapped like yeah
yeah right here you go to a restaurant
and you drop a plate the whole
restaurant hey [ __ ] nice catch
[ __ ] demoralizing just set that up
[ __ ] willie mays
okay all right a little empathy over
there
everybody the whole restaurant laughs oh
yeah california pizza kitchen they're
all [ __ ] laughing
ah and over there in europe a guy drops
a plate
yes and not a word nope and and in
amsterdam there's very few people who
are overweight even
right because everybody rides a bike
everywhere there's more bikes than
people these people
are everybody's lean and if you go over
the bridge
a little red light it's like my aunt
stan in the window waiting for somebody
to [ __ ] her
[Laughter]
is it what is it the red light district
and then is it the blue light district
what's the problem
with that mine had four red lights they
only had one
so that's that's about it give it away
and then you know the closer she got to
it it would smell like pebble
you know you had to keep the door shut i
didn't keep the
i didn't keep the customers [ __ ]
burnt hair
dancing with a gas mask my aunt's hair
oh that's brilliant
hey man it smells like my aunt's hair in
this red light
how about a stroker is that your ass
but that place is pretty amazing when
you walk up and down the street
and women are in the window
selling you their wares yeah yeah and
what was i doing looking for the one
with the biggest steadfast just like
when i was 12.
but you have to make it's in public so
there's a lot of people walking up and
down you have to make that move in front
of everybody
you have to i mean if that's going to
happen they don't look at you like
you're
awful some some i i remember once i came
walking out and these these young girls
from london were just giving the guy ah
they gave him a bunch of [ __ ] cause they
were all drunk and they were making fun
of them for just being with a hooker
or a lady tonight okay
i don't know if any of these during the
day of the day
all right but but over there they live
you know yeah in that way it's over in
an area
yeah and it's before used to be like
trader joe's like there's only one in
sherman oaks
then one in solvang and that was it so
you went over there it was almost like
going to the red light district because
yeah nobody went
unless you were going right trader joe's
and now they're everywhere
yeah but before like sprouts if you went
to sprouts it was like going to get you
know
some [ __ ] choncho on the side because
you're like you know where you're going
you wouldn't tell anybody
that you were going to sprouts but now
you cross the bridge you cross a bridge
right there and there's like a
five-story building and they're all
dancing it's like
it's like amazon right there's a lot of
beautiful yeah
that's quite a place all right moving
right along
kpxi.com here's something with our
millennials where's that
uh lubbock tech where is it
that is also one time when we were on
the road pennsylvania
you go to a hotel in lubbock and
you think they have porn
but they don't they have vhs you have to
go down there
oh and you're like could i have uh
you know pump fiction
and they're like i didn't hear that it
was a latina what american pies
and they give you a vhs oh that's
awesome
that's that's something right out of a
comedy condo there that's nice
right yeah oh oh
remember traveling in the same almost
parlo
[Laughter]
and the lady called me a [ __ ] cochino
when i took the uh
the [ __ ] holly story uh
and she turned around and and it was me
and it was her and then
she gave me the vhs and i reluctantly i
mean i was only one of the deaths so i
took it
and as i got to the elevator she said
call chino
and tick tick tock the vhs it did not
deter it from maintaining an erection
until belly hottie got buddy holly got
to new york
and broke his tooth off on the
intelligence when he broke his tooth up
ruined him all right what else beautiful
ah this again four pencils
prepared that's why i keep saying what
else i know it's uh that's why four man
pennsylvania woke up
four pennsylvania teen girls accused of
setting house fire because
they were bored that's a millennial if
we ever heard him
uh in pennsylvania four teenage girls
ranging from ages 12 to 14
have been arrested on juvenile court
charges of setting a fire that destroyed
an unoccupied ferndale house earlier
this month
how about that that goes on your
permanent record too and they were i
mean that's huge we still burned up in
ferndale
that's going down so what happened so
what do they do to them they call their
parents
and then what yeah they go pick them up
or do they actually do time
because i don't think any of these kids
can do time i don't know i don't know if
kids are getting
sentenced for this or they were released
into custody of
they take their phones away yeah yeah
what about punishment is you can't have
any electronics that would kill these
those kids are like
yeah they're [ __ ] heroin addicts
after an hour yeah right
yeah how about they they didn't survey
they were released into the custody of
their parents
or guardians and their case will be
heard in the cambria
juvenile court so as of right now
they're home though they're not doing
i'm gonna go to that [ __ ] court
they'll tell you what day they're gonna
be there
uh no so do parents have a
do parents have a responsibility to
i mean they're not going to tell you spy
on their kids or
well what what would you do if that was
your kid that's a good one
what would you do what could you do you
can't
you can't put your hands on them no you
throw them across the room but they're
just you can't
take every privilege away from them
though right like i mean they got
nothing
i mean those [ __ ] are burning
houses you think they give a [ __ ]
whether they're like oh man
get on the computer well if they're
bored and they they lit a fire
the sims wouldn't do this that's when
you're really mad
you think that sims build a house so
that that side that one of the little
sims can burn it
roy's using the sims against us um so
i'm gonna say you know we burned stuff
because we were bored but
these kids are burning houses it's it's
not and there's nothing you can do
about it did you ever wear anything
accidentally are you ready
no [ __ ] yeah of course listen well i
lived right there i lived by
there was a wash or the there was a wash
nearby
so there was my house and then another
house and then a cul-de-sac and then the
five freeway
and and by my wall there was a small
area between the city fence which was a
chain-link fence
and our property line but maybe
as wide as this thing remember i'm a
younger kid so i don't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing so
i climb in between
the fence and the wall yeah and then i'm
going like this alone but when i get to
the other side i can't turn around
because there's no room to turn around
so i try to edge out and then i start
crying
and the lady across the wash sees me and
this is about 3 30 now it's like 4
30. and of course the fire
and you know the [ __ ] uh uh salvation
army
everybody the same [ __ ] everybody so
the firemen come
and they got the hat on it's not buckled
because it's not serious you know
yeah we're crazy yeah and the guys on
the thing they got to pull me out
oh my god and the whole neighborhood's
watching now because
i'm stuck in there and they pulled me
out and just as they pulled me out my
grandfather
in his pontiac bonneville come that he
bought at
walter ruff motors on van nuys boulevard
comes around a circle and parks
and he sees me and the fireman is
talking to my grandmother
in the in the front yard and my
grandfather doesn't speak english
but he doesn't need to because the fire
captain said he's fine
poor lamb he just got stuck poor lamb
he's scared but he'll be all right
and my grandfather just nods and he
tells me about that
and i start walking inside and the
fireman turns to go and my grandfather
with his working booth kicks me
right in my [ __ ] like he didn't miss
and kick my cheek
he didn't miss and hit my [ __ ]
tailbone this [ __ ] oh my god
[ __ ] went back and i never saw it
coming because i was walking in the
house
oh and [ __ ] wham right in my
right in my [ __ ] and i i went this
way
yeah i was like a [ __ ] drum major
ready that's college
i went like my shoulders my heels
he kicked me right in my [ __ ]
god and i try to take a [ __ ] not even a
fart
the first wow
if i could lower and test it and the
upper and ten were together
they took an x-ray they were like this
hold it onto each other like this
because and i never saw a cup at least
if you see it coming you you can tighten
that's the first thing that tightens is
your [ __ ] but when you don't know
what's coming that's the last thing
oh god he got a couple digits up there
it went out of round like a golf ball
like if you hit a golf ball back
right now anymore but this thing was
like it was supposed to be like this
this moment was like
oh my god it had a glitch in it
huh well he just said in spanish like he
told he didn't
you know he just went to the chief like
this like thank you sir and then he said
better
than throw i took two steps and i guess
that means hike where he's from
uh boom oh that's right in my oil that
is outstanding
uh i didn't think we'd get there from
the pennsylvania girls
well done uh are we good with uh uh
noose or
are we gonna do some voicemails let's do
some voicemail this [ __ ] is
going to relive a lot of bad bad energy
stories
just [ __ ] kicked me in my [ __ ] he
kicked me right on my hole
that's [ __ ] awesome that was a bad
that was
that was that was a tough one man how
were you and when you got stuck
i was uh man if i and you know what
it's not like trees or anything have
grown over that if i went there right
now
wow i could tell you where he kicked me
right in my oil
listen most people say you know this is
where we've got engaged me this is where
my grandfather [ __ ]
[ __ ] gary you prepped me up took one
[ __ ] step and that would have been
good from [ __ ] 58 yards
gary does everybody know uh you're
pregnant uh awesome i think my
feet left the ground i was like that and
listen i
i've been in a lot of pain in my life
but
none so unexpected as
that mud-covered boot with a steel toe
in case part of the pipes fell on his
foot when he was working
that is hilarious right am i right on my
cool line
not on the side not from you know a lot
of times latin kickers are from you know
they kick sideways not him he was he was
tom
straight straight back and straight up
gave me the old tom dempsey 63 yarder
aka my cooler man
god oh that's hilarious lift me off the
ground
oh hey hey what was your grandma like
that was your grandma like oh
you just took a break after the kick
what can they say to you exactly
it's before the kick which you had to
step in
and block them go for the block go
inside that's what all my grandmother
said to me when she was when i was
growing up
and go inside go inside you have to
write that down because
all right voicemail number one
hey george this is jordan from del rio
texas i had a question
uh i know you played golf a lot just
wanted to see what are some of your
favorite golf courses that
aren't as prestigious uh like my golf
course that you played at here in del
rio sampling springs golf course
kind of like the holes in the walls uh
golf courses so that's uh that's a
question i had uh just curious see if
you can answer that thank you man
appreciate you have a great day
you know what the the the interesting
thing about that is that we did remember
we played that course yeah i do remember
the guy that was there the white titles
hat and that was that place where that
mustang miracle happened where those
latino kids in the 50s uh who didn't
play golf
and you know the owners would throw
a [ __ ] tamale in the water they would
go down and get it bring it back up like
golfer [ __ ] a marine land over there
with latino kids oh god not a dolphin
around okay he'll do it in there [ __ ] it
with doleful
yeah that is a story story throw a piece
of [ __ ] cotton outside he'll go to
the bottom and come back up with the two
tortillas in it
no but that remember the story was yeah
that's an amazing story listen
you know in the 50s you know everybody
was on sense
insensitive it wasn't at least and those
stories are harsh
right oh the ones that they're talking
about elvis stole rock and roll and now
black person could say nothing is there
rich
little richard yeah exactly well all the
black people didn't say anything
like you stole our music sir right and
and and pat boone
and pat boone made a living a
great living just taking what's pat
boone's song
uh oh god i'm about to look that one up
that means some old [ __ ]
but he took all those those songs from
black artists and slowed them down and
paboonized them
and made big hits that was his deal
right was he dead
no i think pat's still around he should
be dead
what about guys like that that you know
that's how that's how i'm going to be in
10 years they'll be talking about me
like [ __ ] baboon
remember his wife uh no his daughter
yeah debbie boone debbie yeah
you light up my life you know back then
you had to use your imagination because
right now on instagram you can see girls
nipples ass
everything and back then you never saw
anybody
unless you walked in on them
most likely with your [ __ ] tia with
one nipple coming out
oh that's nice they look like one of
those those little corn chips bugles
remember those were the [ __ ] finger
tips
yeah and you know i don't know how nip
nipples have changed but none of them go
to the stars
they call star gazers remember that when
they would like you know
from like old movies where the girls
would be dancing or yeah a lady in
cement or some [ __ ] like that
where she's getting dressed except this
mrs livingston and eddie the professor
oh goodness uh yeah when paulo she would
yell at mr eddie's father
uh is there any nobody has uh any of
those
i walked into miami time and her her
nipple was the size of a corn
tortilla i didn't eat tortillas for
almost the last
four years that i lived in that house i
always lost my [ __ ] right there
too like that's awesome
listen none of the if you're trying to
you know build your life
and having a proper sexual identity
don't ever walk in on any of your don't
just do yourself a favor
what knock before do your best or
call them on their phone and say are you
in this room i'm outside the door are
you in here
yeah don't come in here because i don't
put my underwear out okay i'll wait out
here
this cannot that's how my grandmother
was we were playing basketball in the
backyard this was probably
late 60s on a sunday
and she's drinking she didn't really
drink we're playing basketball there
with it with a board that we
you know did with nails and it's
you know she's there and she's like
george give me the ball i used to play
when i was young
i said no grab that's all right and
she's got a skirt on you and she's like
give me see the ball i know i play mira
and she's dribbling and she lifts up her
leg with no underwear on it
yeah [ __ ] damn
[ __ ] it [ __ ] a sea urchin wouldn't have
picked that urchin up and turned it over
okay let the c have that one
and we were just just for a second oh
okay
and how how much she was older like
older older
old enough she was in her late 40s
yeah that'll do it but she has six kids
so that choncho might have been out here
[Laughter]
he looked like it was 112. even the
[ __ ] said don't look at us
oh god us both the lips
listen it [ __ ] up my identity of
of of women because to see your
grandma's working
on a sunday afternoon sunday afternoons
are supposed to be the best part of the
week
and she kicks her leg up and you see
crap you know
oh god that's awesome got that [ __ ]
eve arden hair in there
full big batgirl logo oh
god like that girl
man and heart
those are things man i mean listen that
happened a long time ago
it's almost my birthday week and i still
remember
the shock i couldn't even turn away fast
enough
and she did she was dribbling pretty
good you know and who all saw it was it
just you it was me
and uh i think my mom saw it oh your mom
yeah oh hey and uh
maybe you know maybe my grandfather
would have saw it oh
but it was just a just a gl a glim it
just
threw it out there to scar you the rest
of your life
all right let's move on i never thought
she was attractive but when she was
younger she you know
she wasn't an unattractive woman right
it's just that uh when you're a young
kid you don't want to see an older woman
in that you ever say i've always spanked
the monkey where the mom breaks his leg
and then the
idea that the dude jammed his mom up no
man that's
ah well you know i think i got the yeah
vhs i got it from lubbock texas oh they
call you kochino where you put in your
car
no you just banked the monkey i think
that's what's called spaghetti the
monkey the dude bones his mom
oh you ever seen those taboo ones
well you mean starring kate parker and
tom byron well yeah
apparently that's a yes and peg that was
a young yeah
head yeah the girl the ball like short
hair and pig
was she that she she was like in the
tattoo like two and three right yeah
still tattooing yeah those are awful for
you man don't don't listen if you're out
there don't look at porn because it's
it's not the real world
okay all right next do you ever have a
teacher
like i had a teacher in fourth grade
well here's another that's a good one
too
i can't use your name but i had a
teacher in fourth grade miss rudorfer
and she had a couple of [ __ ]
tornadoes at the end of her tethos
you needed to call [ __ ] and uh stanley
steamery to get the
right wrench that fit that knob right
there
i mean she has you know and just in the
area that we grew up in
it's not cold a lot yeah but she would
it would be colder she's like you kids
come in here and when you see
a goddamn english leather knob coming
out of her [ __ ] bra
like a goddamn fist
oh god to her bra you're and she don't
even see it but you could feel you know
oh god and i it it's not good for you
ah well that's when i saw donna rita
when i was a little kid up
in person like she owned a lingerie
store no
way i didn't know and she would go in
there and she was
beautiful wow she owned a lingerie i
never knew she don't read lingerie
it's a wonderful life it sure was when
you can see her bend over you'll see a
little
the lines going up a little just a
little bit crooked right
it's just crooked enough all wrong man
all bad all lead to the road of
destruction
that's right that's right you know i
allegedly when i was on the road early
on a girl was doing laundry a lot of
times you stay in apartments
yeah and a girl was doing laundry
and as her lingerie was drying i took a
pair of her underwear and i went up and
jacked up did you really wow there's
some honesty
goddamn so so these are live i decided
the guest book
charles manson dahmer
how about that man stole some chones and
fired one off wow that's uh
that's that's honest that's amazing and
i left mine in there
she would not
and i got hers you can match them like
those hearts that you break
and you put the two hearts like you know
really do you see somebody and you have
one broken heart
right and then when you meet they match
you're seeing it out by the way all
right robin robinson
rub it rub it
well that i don't know if we answer the
question of any unsung golf
courses uh i didn't mention any golf
course [ __ ] yeah man
but he mentioned the story so that was
that's beautiful it's a fantastic yeah
thank you for that that's just there's a
lot of great municipal courses that
are designed hey the wanna country club
is designed by the guy who
does who designed pebble beach i didn't
know that wow
so there's still a lot of great golf
courses a lot of public golf courses
because
even though um exclusion
is still not as uh
widely spread as it's it was
uh you know decades ago golf still
thrives
so you know golf was maybe the most
exclusive game
um so to be a member at a couple of
country clubs
i get what the question is but always i
don't think you'll go wrong with the
city
with the city course like griffith park
and we drive home from here i drive when
you see growth park there
or you know i learned at el carisso but
really kind of anywhere where we're on
the road we would sometimes find
yeah places that worked great country
clubs met those people in vegas
angel park when it took [ __ ] 12 hours
that's the only thing does that mean
yeah but i mean you know you get hit by
a [ __ ] plane where do you go
you know the only reason i went to
better places is because
the [ __ ] planes land in there yeah
they're like van nuys remember
i played van gaal i'm getting clipped by
a [ __ ] dhl [ __ ] played landed from
singapore
right he's lowering his landing gear he
takes your hat off
yeah another close man those are close
like vans
yeah bad eyes yeah all right that time
one time i was across the ground like a
100-foot putter that arnold says
if you make this i'll blow you and i
made it took off running i think i saw
him for three weeks
like you're gonna make them and we went
together there oh that's hilarious i was
gonna make him pay right there
oh man i go hey man he goes hey george
you make it i'll blow you and i made it
then i look he
[ __ ] took off that makes the story
greater like you're about to take
advantage i didn't see him really till
graduation and
ah well i felt like running a few times
after you got a birdie so
let alone an eagle we had a yeah yeah
but but you know um
i would say that uh
is there any woman that loves a man that
plays golf no i don't think so
so wonder the guys on the pga tour are
that good because
women do not most women do not like
when the husband plays golf and would
always call me like
where are you at i'm like [ __ ] i'm in
the still in the driveway i can take it
let me get over there and just would
call me five [ __ ] times ten times
where are you at and i always tell her
like i was on the 13th hole
it's like number three oh my god
well it's a long game i mean it takes
five hours and looking now
you know we've been away from each other
for ten years did it matter
yeah there you go i talked to her today
and she said uh
you're not getting i was a little bit
you know elusive i'm not sure why
and she says wait a minute you're all
right i said yeah i'm good she goes
you're getting married
and i said no are you because that would
help me
oh he's a big fan of anne serrano uh you
know what handsome
he said i always let love dance ends
you know hey listen ann gave me part of
her body so that i couldn't
still live to pay expenses there you go
well done
that's well thank you anne thank you and
she was always unbelievable to me so
nothing nothing for her i was a married
tour you know she didn't like the spy
and she was right
yeah so i would say you know i would say
she never said a bad word about you but
my grandmother
my grandmother would always say i don't
like this guy or that guy a lot of times
she was you know what
a lot of times you know you have your
nucleus of guys like your arnold ernie
andy carey
those guys but then you might bring up
another guy that she doesn't really know
and those are the people she didn't know
and of the two that she disliked the
most
juan died a long time ago and the other
one has spent quite a bit of time in
the prison oh oh oh wow so nailed it but
also
i had a when i was in junior high or
high school i mean sorry
when i was in high school there was a
guy who was in gymnastics
who had a fantastic body and i did not
i was the third baseman and uh the third
baseman
through the delightful so so i had a
third baseman's body so so
the girl that i went out with would see
this guy
and they would say why are you with that
guy and why
wouldn't you be with that guy and then
when we graduated from high school that
guy was maybe two years out
and up here not far from where we grew
up he was a security guard
and then he ran into like he was like
the west coast son of sam he ran into a
couple that was making out
and he threw the dude and the girl was a
little like a little fatty like a little
fatty girl yeah but the guy was a
normal person you know i'm doing that oh
my god
the guy was a normal because a lot of
times in relationships i think you know
we can relate that the guy's normal size
and the wife or the girlfriend sorry is
a little bit
extra and if you don't think that's true
take the
wife jean test take a pair of your
wife's jeans
and you put them on and see if you can
button the ones that she can't
oh my god not a popular test but is that
okay you
so so the you know the skinny dude
went way over
and then you know uh
uh exhibit b i don't know if they called
her that chord
i'm just saying um you labeled it
yourself
exhibit b-plus didn't make it down
because she was
you know a little bit of gorita she got
stuck on one of the rocks
it wasn't a moon rock that dude was
trying to put pylo on but but
she went she didn't go down that far
but his mistake was to think that i mean
it's really awful i should even i
shouldn't even be saying this
this isn't why they made podcasts so you
could i will i mean is that the reason
why
i don't know i'm not sure how this but
is there any podcasts that people listen
to that feel like they're a better
person after [ __ ] that
so he he he he throws the
you know the b-plus with niacin
oh man like a vitamin yes over
and she doesn't make it to the bottom oh
no and crawls up
and lit i mean honestly lives but crawls
up and he was longed and he was gone
yeah and then called
um you know the police and since he was
kind of on the job you know protecting
this area
he has been in that prison
that you can see on the way into las
vegas on the right i think that's where
oj was that dude has been in that prison
since
1980. oh my god
so he's never getting out i mean there's
i mean that's
41 years life oh man and
how bad was my character the girls are
still [ __ ] saying you should have
been with him instead of me
i'm out here free human being
talking over there a guy you got to see
through six inches of [ __ ] glass oh
man that's quite a story
okay here's my question what is the
state of
you yours and your brother's
relationship
right now your brother brad
my brother brad you guys talk all the
time are you estranged
like that's personal because that's the
whole idea of one question
i had no idea his name brad horvath
bradley joseph horton
helen up george with an f hey have you
seen bradley joseph
i heard you're gonna talk to his brother
yeah right so we're we're um
uh fantastic i i do not talk to my
brother an awful lot to be honest with
you i mean
i mean i don't it's not like we talk
weekly or even monthly a lot but
we uh so you really are becoming mexican
[ __ ] married to him
i don't know [ __ ] yeah i talked to my
brother in six years
hey you could thank her by the the
[ __ ] the the other side of my heart
for that all right
no uh he just came to a show i did a
show in uh
in uh colorado he went to the show we
hung out i mean he
we're brad and i are tight just doesn't
matter if we talk or not he said he's
[ __ ] uh
then i can say i'm tight too i never see
him
i see him as much as you do he's not
even my brother he likes you a lot
um
has has what's his wife's name pam
has pam the non-stick oven spray
and uh marcy ever met
are you oh they're uh they're trouble
you're kidding me
no they're trouble together they get
along too well they uh
they like to imbibe they like the uh
libations
how many kids they have between the
twelve eleven no
no marcy yeah marcie is ten pam has one
[ __ ] other fear of some bird killer
yeah exactly no i already some you saw
me sunblock for
under my feet why because they're in the
air so much
we didn't know that the vacation was
going to turn out like the kids were
when they practiced popcorn or
they just kicked that football between
my mom's legs
and she saw his feet together
but but uh so so what what about what
about brad and your dad
um it's it's uh yeah bra we're all
really
don't say it close because you know we
we were very tight people like i said i
guess i could say my mom and i are close
we haven't talked to 25 years but when
you talk to are you like hey we you know
like you know each other it seems like
we
we didn't miss a step my brother and i i
swear i can't i
won't have to talk to brad for six weeks
and then i get on the phone with him and
it's like we didn't
[ __ ] are boring as [ __ ] because well
that's true if you're gonna go six
without talking to each other
and it feels like you just saw each
other it's that yeah
he's the nicest guy in the world how do
you know he lets it grow too i think he
probably trims them at this point
i think i'm guessing because the calling
man they don't manscape it i think i'm
the only one huh
sea urchins in the country i think his
wife trusts him a little more
the nurse is going to come in here and
she's going to trim you and marks you
from across the world although they're
not
she said she finds me on manscape she's
all where is that [ __ ] i'll kill her
that's marcy but uh yeah brad probably
escapes i guess and
what about when was the last time you
and brad and your dad were all together
uh 1971 the lunar module
apollo 12. well to be honest with you my
father has has hunkered down
during the covet so i haven't seen seen
my dad during cover but but right before
then
the three was running tell everybody
what you would the little background on
your pops
my dad uh very uh straight lace uh who
was in the navy wasn't he
he was in the air force eagle scout guy
like all-american guy all american
athletes
he was an eagle scout he was an eagle's
did he touch you inappropriately
growing up and putting [ __ ] money on
all the kids
he's got some story about his counselors
though you're gonna want you want the
bed sheet
come over here under the garage under
the garage some special looking badges
that we couldn't explain
um yeah he was an eagle scout straight
lace guy went to the air force
first job out of or out of the air force
was ibm
stayed with ibm the whole time was in
computers and how many years like 35
years
30 years so my father took the the
80-year deal they had if your age
and years served in ibm is 80 you got
full benefits in your retirement so he
was there 30 years and he was 50.
he retired at 50 with full bennies so he
laughed great
so then he uh then i'd never seen him
dance a step and he
okay so check this out everybody so
brian's pops yes was the ibm dude he
wore a motorcycle
with the gloves with the with the
fringes looking for adventure
yep that was i'll pull it into a denny's
that was wrong
around killing slipping on some black
guys out there popping wheelies
little ones no snow stands i heard he
would settle up in the union plaza out
there in vegas
for a stint and stand out in front of
the whiskey pete's out there
without autographs for his leather pants
so so he was a motorcycle dude
yeah just a guy not a dancer yeah no
never saw him dance honestly a step not
a serious one maybe joking around but
never saw my father dance
and uh he became a ballroom dance
instructor
not just a dancer he became an
instructor and i was like
i didn't understand i didn't understand
what he was saying you thought that he
might be trying to tell you i thought
that was a metaphor for
living an alternative lifestyle it is
listen i saw some dude what type of
dancing in front of the street he wasn't
even in the studio
he was dancing to the reflection of the
sidewalk into that i said hey man
i'll buy you some glasses and i thought
you have to be [ __ ] dancing in the
reflection hey
but uh remember the roller skater you
ever seen the guy that roller skater
robertson
with the dreads this dude like had zero
body fat
and like dolphin shorts and like uh he
was an older guy
and he would dance on roller skates
for hours where was that robertson and
beverly i got to see that i got to see
videos i have to look him up
those guys are classic what makes them
do that
acid probably pc yeah right okay so so
okay so your dad
moves to arizona moves yeah just before
he moved to arizona he was living in san
jose california and then that's when he
got into ballroom dancing
and he became an instructor and then he
moved to arizona he became an instructor
okay so everybody that's listening have
has anybody in your family done anything
or any of your friends done anything
completely
out of the norm because you never saw
your dad dancing one step
and then he moves to arizona yeah
and becomes a ballroom dance instructor
so he had to take
all the classes yeah he had he had to
get to that level
fernando's yeah and he he did he
he's like one of these really focused
guys he's a very athletic guy and uh
and i didn't know what to think about i
saw him do a couple of competitions and
stuff it was like a
trip and i i like what were the
competition like
like like a double tree no they would
have them in like the big balls
i'm here for the dance competition yeah
uh room 102.
what they had these bit they were huge
deals it was a big
what did you think when you saw your dad
out there at first i was like
i was like oh what was he wearing like
like a little like a one-piece
white silhouette white tails chiffon
white tails that was awesome and
very thin yeah so but uh i have to give
it to my dad he
became the the uh king of ballroom of
prescott arizona i mean he was just had
a lot of students and stuff
and i never what do you think about what
was it the woman that he was involved
with that made him
well my dad's my dad gets into stuff
like motorcycle racing my father got
into
he started well before that he was in
the tennis he never played tennis in his
life
got way into tennis and then he got into
motorcycles got crazy in the motorcycles
almost killed himself going a million
miles an hour and then
his wife it was his second wife i'd like
to slow it down now
and put on my capezios that's right i'm
gonna do the ballet to brown for a
second
yeah so so you went to a competition and
when he was done
and he did the whole yeah just stand up
and kill him
he was amazing he was just amazing and
the thing was
he was a good dancer because he's a good
athlete but he's
an amazing teacher like i saw him teach
a class it was
it was amazing my father had these
people with two left feet and he had him
going
he was he had them all excited and ready
to go and they were young too these
people were like
learning how to dance for their wedding
my dad had them dancing out of their two
left shoes
it was outstanding you know most guys at
their wedding say it's
really like going to the finish line
because you're dancing in the clubs
trying to get a woman to like you and
then they they say
do you ever go dancing you're like yeah
sure i love dancing but you really don't
you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you dance at your wedding dance
and then you when she's once that is
over and you sit down you're like that
guy never had to [ __ ] dance again
exactly and you're a [ __ ] i'm a made
man right and meanwhile your wife's like
oh i can't wait to learn the next song
it's like
horrible but my father uh amazing it was
really
shockingly cool tell everybody everybody
tell everybody that when your dad goes
to events with marcy
like he brings his shoe you change his
shoes yeah oh
yeah he's just he's just a
a dancer now now he just likes like uh
choreographed dancing he doesn't like
when people just jam so he'll go to like
a wedding family wedding
his shoes he hates it and he'll have his
shoes and he'll do some
like serious dancing because he can't
stand but he changes his shoes like he
walks up and
he walks in with some shoes that he gets
he comes out with something we're about
to take it to the next level he puts on
his camera right here
i'll show you dancing and then you're
very well
i see you growing everything i never
really love people but my father
take my breath away suddenly you're in
my life
part of it oh god he uh
he uh is 80 years old and can dance
he's eight years eight he's in here he's
not a big dude he's like a little like
popeye
dude on the crackerjack sub yes like a
little lean guy
and uh really like uh wiry muscular
guy and uh he can dance his ass
seriously it's shocking if anybody
wanted to get a lesson from ronnie
what were they just finding them in
globe arizona they used to be able to
find out it used to be called mile high
uh dancing studio and that's not like a
place they [ __ ] make meth thing
yeah they might do a little that's like
hey
[Laughter]
they put stuff in there what's in there
uh i'd love to see i'd love to have you
watch around atlanta guatemala they
unpack you
oh yeah you catch a turnaround flight i
never met your dad man like you never
wanted me to meet him no we were gonna
meet him in uh you know what happened we
were gonna meet him
in phoenix he went to a show and then we
ended up hanging out with nils lofgren
that was a you know amazing because nils
came in with his wife
and we were hanging out and then by the
time we got out my father had to go yeah
but
he had to go up because he was what do
you have
a [ __ ] foxtrot lesson at seven in the
morning
[Laughter]
yeah i hope he uh i hope he listens to
this but he understands that i
am a huge fan no no no i i don't think
you never you know said anything about
him dancing was good but but you know
he's well first of all i mean you can't
believe that like the guy's 80
and he's dancing and bringing people joy
by dancing yep and uh and he was always
like i never got any joy from dancing
but
i'm not like that when i was married
anne says to me i'm thinking about
getting a piano for the house like
what the [ __ ] you want to do and she
goes for music because when you when you
think of a piano what do you think i
said
i think [ __ ] noise right you think i
don't think
she's a [ __ ] kid yep that's what
happens in uh in my house
the little kids just dance all over that
that piano
what so brad is your brother brad is
like like a like uh
he still coaches football yep he coaches
somebody play hockey he did not play
hockey
but he was a hockey dad so his son
played hockey his whole life but uh
brad's football guy always wanna be a
football player when he was a kid
remember when you're a kid uh you know
you tell people you want to be comedian
my brother don't [ __ ] talk for me
[ __ ] for myself
so my brother used to always talk about
my brother always said i want to be a
football player i want to
eat just football his whole life so now
he's a financial planner slash
football coach for semi-pros so he's
like like grown men yeah oh yeah grown
men yeah
the colorado flames i think they call
him cover
the [ __ ] halftime [ __ ] show he's
out there taping ankles
with the [ __ ] uh with the thing with
the fire on both sides
he's the baton twirler
uh my sister-in-law pam brad's uh you
should do that she was a she is a baton
twirling
uh master she is a coach of that how
about that she used to dance in vegas
brad's wife so she was a dancer in vegas
and ended up [ __ ] twirling batons
well i mean she she tore about times
before that's gross
i love it that's that's that's how it
was that's almost once
watching your vagina in a [ __ ] mobile
[ __ ] bathroom on the way back to
barstow
can you pull over into the whiskey pizza
i got to clean my oil
oh yeah a little gaming in the car
all right man thank you for answering
the question ah thanks for one question
question i made through i love you
family no but you know i think it's
interesting man my dad's story is really
really
he's been he's but now as of now he's
been
a dance instructor as long as he worked
for ibm which he retired from
equal 30 years of peace wow isn't that
crazy
i mean yeah he's in really good yeah
really good shape
yeah but yeah because that girl that i
well a girl a woman
that was in another area here in town
was
like a world-class champion and i
remember
with the whole big you know like to the
world she was brazilian
world champion ballroom dancer and i
remember somebody else's
wife that you know who was
a dancer but like in arizona going to
competitions
and then i said to her i know a woman
that's a world
champion ballroom dancer and he's like
do you remember her name
and i said i i don't and you know she
says to me
oh you know they got a lot of regions i
go no no i think i think this is the
a world class she goes yeah but it's
probably like regional so i looked her
up and i showed it to her she goes oh
yeah that's the whole world
oh really so she was the real deal yeah
oh man hey to see one of those things
like they have all the levels of course
and when you watch the world class
people
dance it's ridiculous and that is in
that in no way
it's easy to to uh to dance no like i
know guys you know make fun of dancing
and like yoga and all that stuff but
to be a dancer
you have to be you know you watch
dancing with the stars oh yeah
oh yeah of course my my nephew uh
another one
he was he uh learned he's big
bodybuilder guy like really
fit great dancer but he learned about
bomb dancing just to meet
like older women and he would just he
would just
reel him in that's [ __ ] spooky he
would reel him in i mean
he was like he was in his 20s and people
in there the women in the 30s like mid
30s we just no
longer women like 84.
i mean on slow nights that was on
tuesday so one time we were in the dead
one time we were in palm
we were in palm desert we were in
aquinta and we went to
a bar that is frequented by people that
i don't want to say they're older than
me but they are older than me but i'm
right in there
it's like over 50 crowd okay and
i had a goatee mustache
and this old lady came over and asked me
to dance
and and i said that i wasn't you know
injured in the war in korea that i
couldn't dance oh my gosh
and she you know she walked away and she
was wearing like a sequence
like a joker and a queen dress
ah just for the picture and i went to
and remember we were playing golf the
next morning
and after the ninth hole i came back and
i shaved yes
because i was so [ __ ] horrified that
a 90 year old woman would
think i was her age that i shaved all my
just with no
razor just like a [ __ ] teeth just cut
some
[ __ ] soap
man but and she danced right i mean you
said no but she ended up dancing
you could see her out there right if i
remember right she was dancing out there
without you i think sorry yeah she got
out there that was her thing but i think
if you
like you know how old's your cousin the
nephew that does that well uh he was in
his twenties now
he likes to bang old ladies well i mean
when he was a kid he did now his old
ladies are old ladies
you know what i mean like if if he did
that now
and i liked although you know you know i
like older white ladies with big titties
so
but now i really do i really do i really
do
that's like almost like lee merriweather
huh that's a reference that's a great
that's a great guy who else uh uh
um joan bernard
oh really julian uh lee merryweather joe
the girl from uh vegas phyllis davis
she passed away yeah um he was uh ethel
merman when i was a little kid i should
jack off
i got a feeling i [ __ ] shoot him
all over my [ __ ] house just guess she
had a big old chest dinner
i told joan rivers that uh
she was doing those universal
commercials i had a crusher she goes
what the [ __ ] is she looking at she goes
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you oh
that's awesome that's a joke i had a big
crush on you as a kid you know oh yeah i
wear i said when you're doing those
unicorn commercials she goes what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
how classy she was great i would love to
hear herself jon rivers were the best
fantastic all right well so you know i
got a lot of respect for this guy right
here yes of course a lot
i know that helped me out of a few
things when i needed any questions about
law enforcement he was always very happy
to help me uh you want to introduce him
yes uh 22 years lapd
as a senior lead officer among many
other things
victor aguilar did you uh retire from
the police force
yes sir and how many how many what do
you say the average
uh career of a not an lapd officer but
just an officer in general
i would say ranges between 20 and 27
only the
the ones that want to stay longer
divorce or whatever they'll say i'm
like 32 33 years on and after like 30
years
would you could would you want to be
where would you want to be
if you started out you know on the
streets as a police officer 30 years
later
what would somebody aspire to be a
detective or i think a lot of them were
inspired to be a detective 3 level 3
lieutenant captain
some of them have higher expirations
like being
commander deputy chief and chief yeah um
the reason you know remember the reason
i wanted
uh victor to be in here is because
i think you know you know we have
daughters and
things like that and i think that this
time that we're living in right now
is um
what's the right word um
like when some a lot of people are
pretending to be people they're not
correct and
i think a lot of that is even in the law
enforcement man like
you know i was watching these things on
youtube where guys were pretending to be
police officers and they're not
yes and they have a car with lights and
they pull people over
and they take their driver's license
they take their information
and they're they're really doing traffic
stops with red lights on their car which
is against a lot right
yes you can't i can't have a crown vic
with lights on it the the law says that
it cannot be
uh a red forward-facing red light right
that's a felony
you can have blue you can have felony
you can have an amber light
and a lot of people try to do that and
try to pull people over with those
lights
so fyi for all your listeners everybody
that follows
i said no no don't be pulling over and
get to know your local police station
okay so that's a that's a great point
get to know this is not even just right
here in los angeles or
wherever we are this is just everywhere
in the country all over the world
probably
get to know your police department where
it is
have the number handy put in your phones
i don't have it
you know everybody's calling 9-1-1 but
also when something happens you have to
know where where to go
and um i think it's i think it's just
it's scary what's going on because you
know they pull people over
pull girls over pull women over they
take their information
they're they're really exercising a full
traffic stop with no other comps around
right and they can put you in the car i
think some people you know
i think you know a civilian would know
that sometimes
cops have unmarked cars so if he says
hey you know i'm a detective but i can
do
traffic stops get out of the car and
they cuff you and put you in the back
seat you're gone
like nobody would even know you're gone
correct
so if somebody gets pulled over by a by
a car that's not a black and white
or not a higher patrol or not a
motorcycle cop what other
police can put what other type car can
pull somebody over
well generally i mean usually here in
los angeles and anywhere else it should
be the same way where there
should not be a uh unmarked police car
trying to pull you over it's always
going to be
marked black and white if anything else
other than that
you should be dialing 9-1-1 as they're
trying to pull you over and be able to
give description of whoever's pulling
you over
in your street where you're at okay so
if somebody pulls you over and
they're aggressive because in youtube i
was watching that guy that guy's like
get the [ __ ] over to the side now
and the car goes over and
that's when you should be hitting 9-1-1
saying i'm just got pulled over on my
street right here this guy is
yelling at me i'm not sure he's the
police officer and he's trying to make
me get out of the car
that is correct 100 okay
and what what possesses somebody like a
regular person
to think that they could were they going
to get a badge at the army
like surplus stores they get like the
fatigues or like a dark blue
thing it's not an lapd officer this guy
had it he had like sergeant stripes
and it's not sergeant stripes he had a
badge but it's not a badge
right correct you know you can actually
buy that on ebay now
fake stuff all over the place and you
order them and you have them
the biggest thing is you know what be
aware of your surroundings also again
i'll say it again it has to be a
forward-facing red light
because even if a wannabe cop a fake cop
does that that's a double whammy because
they're pulling somebody over
violating their rights and you're also
putting that red it just carries
enhancements for them to go to prison
longer so it tells you they're not
[ __ ] around because if you have a red
light facing forward
that's not a misdemeanor that's a felony
right somebody in a
in an unmarked like a super sport tinted
windows trying to be cool
and then they put that you know the old
streets
every time they turn it falls off but
it's obviously you you
said it's you're very familiar with it
so how often does it happen do you know
how many times have you dealt with it
you know it happens almost all the time
one instance that uh that i can remember
too is a few years back
before i retired there was a group about
10 security guards these guys were
security guards they actually had
unmarked police vehicles that they buy
at auctions
and they were targeting a bunch of uh
young ladies coming out of the nightclub
so they'll work like they'll be
working criminally but you see that's
what i would do if i was pretending to
be a police officer from the time i left
my house
of course i would be committing felonies
i thought my weenie out
in your red lights your red light
is out hey listen foreign worry about my
penis just let me see
let me see your driver's license
and uh so that was in the that was early
like in the morning i'm talking about
three
three and on because usually one to two
or two thirty
real cops we're out there trying to
monitor everything making sure
everybody's getting home
safe yeah and uh so after the time three
to six because there's
right that's the time to change over and
doing that stuff right in a lot of the
yes sir and a lot of the security guards
that are doing these crimes or want to
be cops are there doing these crimes
also
they um tend to study when the shifts
are changing for real police so there's
like a half hour 45 minutes for them to
do crimes
so during the daytime we also came
across a lot of
a lot of these individuals that would
target fruit vendors
you know like raspados paletas and also
uh food trucks and they will hit them up
and say hey you're
you're a violation of this whatever
they'll go through their pockets
supposedly confiscate their money take
all their money and in some instances we
have these individuals
make them burritos or make them whatever
espados and stuff and
you know they mess with the wrong person
though because some of them
you know we they'll always go to
meetings especially because i used to
haul a lot of meetings and they'll be uh
i would tell them make sure you watch
anything in their faces or any tattoos
anything that you can describe and and
then we'll hit them up
and this guy said yeah he's got like a
big red up mark on his
face uh like a mole i mean you're doing
that and you have a moe in your face
you weren't thinking either you're doing
that with the mole on your face
that's pretty good stop looking at my
ball i know they'll never recognize you
straight ahead um um
but what possesses somebody to pretend
to be a police officer like what
what's the psychology behind that you
know i've actually spoke to a few of
them because i like to get to know the
criminals to see what they think about
some of them a lot of them wanted to be
police officers they took a test and
they failed they took it again and again
and they failed
uh so they become security guards and
then they start
you know you'll always pay attention
like when i was a police officer be on
the streets you'll always see security
guys kind of checking you out and you
kind of know this guy's kind of weird
you know
and sure enough before you know it
they'll bring a man because he did
something stupid and he gets booked for
that
so i think that what possesses is the fa
the fact that they wanted to be police
officers they probably want to see what
it feels to pull people over or whatever
and here they are doing this stupidness
but they're also not only
are you stopping people illegally you
put in the forward facing red light
you're going through their pockets
but you know you're putting yourself in
that predicament with something else
might happen like you know if it's a
young lady
they might proceed to rape her kill her
yeah right and now you're
in you know in a [ __ ] world of hurt oh
yeah i wouldn't trust him because first
of all i probably think that the guy's
not using his real name
the badge isn't real the car is not real
the lights aren't real so
everything is a lie yeah so he says you
know officer verga
pull it over your choice and uh
the already know the penal code um
but i think that happens all over the
country i don't think it's just it's
just
definitely all over the count but
they're always going to try to prey on
the people that
have a little bit of ignorance about the
law okay when
when the stuff was going on uh like a
year ago when people fight in the
streets
who were the dudes in the all green
uniforms with no
name tag or any badge do you want to say
or you're scared
they might take you are you scared i can
tell you that there were not a regular
police officers they were actually
were from came from washington
they're federal right so they were for
real
yes serious if they grabbed you they
didn't know
you didn't recognize who they were
anymore you were be gone and somehow
a lot of the people ended up calling
from washington dc wherever they were
transported some of them were
i think was oregon was another base that
they had so it was like come and get me
theo because i'm in
i'm in washington do you ever see those
guys yeah i saw well there was a little
like a special kind of like who are
these yeah no names yeah yeah
they got weapons they got green they
don't have any tags
or sometimes dark and they can take you
yes and throw you in the truck and take
you away that's frightening
and they're affiliated with our
government right
correct but it's not a it's not a
sanctioned
it's not the police no and this
according to what they were saying is
they were targeting people that were
really a nuisance and a real risk risk
yeah
humans that were out there because some
of them had guns some of them were
getting
you know some of them actually they went
to knock on their door and take them out
of their house because they knew who
they were
you ever see that documentary on that
guy that is is
is training those police officers and
the police departments
are letting them um go and serve
warrants
no i didn't see that the police officers
don't do it they farm it out to
these guys all in black and they would
knock on your door
and they got a search warrant no badge
no identification but
they farmed them out to do it the police
don't do it
yeah that's i'm sure that's going to be
in another state or another another city
because here you know just like you had
a couple people
in the news lately there was one uh
taylor i
believe that was her last name she got
shot right the cops these are actually
always going in
you know usually here you get a lot of
people
if a cop knocks on your door say search
warrant within like less than 30 seconds
your door will be taken down
a lot of the people are fake they're not
going they'll be knocking on the door
forever so
that should give you the time to down
9-1-1 and have somebody respond that is
real police together okay so somebody's
knocking on your door
and they continue to knock on your door
and they look like they're official
they're not
because a police officer would knock on
your door
and then usually have a search warrant
kick the door in
right they're not going to be knocking
for half an hour trying to get you to
open the door correct
like i saw a video too there's a guy out
there that's on a ring camera knocking
on the door
a young guy with a with a suit and a
badge on his hip
like right on his belt and the lady's
like what what what who do you work for
he just open the door
and he they didn't open the door because
he was a fake cop
he's going around trying to get people
open the door right and
i'm thinking that this is going to be
we're going to see this happen more
because of
power because of somebody wanting power
over somebody else
and what's ultimate power is to have
authority over somebody
yeah like you're you're driving up and
down the street
and you see some people out there that
might be making something drinking
you come back later on and they say hey
we got a complaint from your neighbors
that there was loud music is drinking
you know can i look around i think
yeah because everybody wants to be
important yeah and i think
that's that's how they get it you could
be ha
what maybe you could tell us what's like
the biggest or easiest tell
that impersonators give like what what's
a sign that will say that guy's not real
to someone like me who's like say hey
some guy pulled me over
what's the biggest mistake they make i
think they search you and they just
search your anus or your media
i think that one of the biggest key
things is if he doesn't give you a
ticket
and he went through your pockets right
or got your quality he doesn't actually
write you up a regular police officer is
gonna tell you you know his name
her name the reason why they stopped you
while you're still in the car
and then he's gonna ask you for your
license your registration
and your insurance so those three papers
should be out
given you never hand your wallet you
never hand anything like that
that's when you know it's a professional
uh officer a real a police officer
somebody else says you you know he
actually gets the door and opens it for
you and tries to reach into your pocket
that's true you should be putting the
car on driving dragging that fool around
when a cop when a cop pulls somebody
over
um and they get attitude from somebody
how does that change the cops
disposition he comes up and he goes what
did i do like wow what did i do
i didn't do anything what are they is
there is there a pattern like lesson
registration
then you say i notice that you over here
you didn't do this
and then if they start arguing with you
where does that go
you know it goes two ways the way i
would take it personally myself would be
your attitude's going to dictate whether
i give you a ticket or not
um if you're a co i got people that i
stopped
and they went through a red light and it
was this guy i pulled over it was a it
was a
a paisa straight out like like us you
know and it was like three in the
morning he went
right through the light and i pulled him
over and he had like two aprons in his
in his uh in his car and i'm like hey
sir the reason i pulled here because i
don't speak
i don't speak english and i'm like so i
told him hey you need this i said do you
have your
driver's license he says no but i got
three kids that are hungry
my wife died and i have three jobs so
even if this guy would have given me an
attitude the
i told oh and he goes are you still
going to give me a ticket sorry you know
what man
if i had tickets to disneyland i will
give them to you that's the only tickets
i'm going to give you because
i felt bad you know i was like wow i'm
admiring the guy at the same time and
i'm like i felt like
really really small because i'm like man
here i am pulling this poor hard worker
out but at the same time it was my job
to pull him over because he went through
the light and i didn't and i asked
i told him too you need to take a red
bull or something be awake
because you those kids are depending on
you and you don't want to die in a car
accident here oh wow
so um like that like everybody has a
story right
yes then when you pull people over like
that guy you let go
um because you're like oh my this poor
dude like here but
um
are people trying to get out of it or
are they willing to take the ticket like
if i did some like all the times i got
pulled over
i knew what i did i wasn't trying to get
out of it
um not many stop you know let me get
stopped a lot by the cops but
i wasn't trying to fight the cops i
wasn't trying to say what pisses a cop
off if you say can i have your badge
number or your supervisor
correct what what's the one that's going
to be like okay [ __ ] this this
is going to
not going to that's going to go well now
yeah all of those just generally
you asked for my badge number my serial
number my supervisor whatever you're
pretty much saying
you're nobody whatever so i'm like okay
i'll show you how nobody i am and
proceed to give a ticket um i gave a
ticket to um
i guess affluent person uh i forgot
daughter can i say that yeah we can
it's cut off designer i pulled this uh
actually it was me and uh my partner and
i
and he pulled her over because she's
like driving erratically
she was driving um you're driving a a
azure is that like a rolls-royce
or bentley one of those two cars so
anyways uh
we we we pulled her over and she gave
lip to my uh to my partner like do you
know who i am i'm this i'm that and she
was smoking and she was
i think she was 16 and a half wow and my
partner was shaking and he's like
i can't give her the ticket man look at
the car she's driving she says she's
somebody
i'm like [ __ ] that so i went around and
said you know what give me your license
registration and insurance
i said you don't talk to my partner like
that i said you got to show a little bit
more respect
then i looked and it's like you know
there's not a real license is it will be
valid until she's 18.
so i gave her a ticket and she was oh
you'll see me in court
we go to court there's a juvenile court
and she's there
with two attorneys and she's like trying
to
like say you know that you usually like
to give affluent people uh tickets
oh you take uh do you take great
pleasure and doing that i go no
i take great pleasure in educating
people and teaching them
a lesson i said because we are police
officers we're trying to help people out
and she's you know saying that you know
she's somebody and she could also get
killed and get somebody killed that way
she was driving
right judge was having none of that just
guilty
oh beautiful so that was the case on
that one
what about uh you know so i would
probably say that
if you're a police officer that there's
a
a camaraderie amongst officers yes right
but they
they all don't get along but there is
respect
for somebody on the job that they would
say on the job if you get pulled by a
cop
they all don't have the same attitude
like there isn't like unless you go to
baskin robbins everybody acts the same
no matter what thirty-one flight
happened yeah like a
okay what flavor like same routine but
with police like they're they're all
different some
maybe a little bit louder
personality-wise they don't all have the
same personality
no and uh i think the minute that
a motorist even if you think that you
got pulled over for no reason
i i wouldn't and i think it's probably
good advice
not to not to go off on a cop
and and just start laying into him you
[ __ ] don't have anything better
to do than do
like you don't want to do that right
correct uh one of the things that
impresses me usually
and uh because it teaches they teach us
this
in at the academy but you know when
people actually go out and do it i mean
that a lot of people have have been
getting trained you know when people
pull when cops pull you over
put your two windows down your two front
windows down and if you got real tinted
in the back pull those down
put your hands with open palms on the 10
and two on the steering wheel which you
know just side by side
say officer you know just to let you
know this is who i am
i got my id whatever and then they'll
say okay put them down and that
kind of makes them at ease and they kind
of know okay
this guy's already going with the flow
let's just chill let's see what he's
about
and you're probably gonna get out of a
ticket 99 times out of a hundred
easily when you play by the rules but if
you come up with an attitude
you're probably going to get a ticket 99
times out of 100. but if they pull you
over
and they say you know how fast you were
going you most likely were speeding
they're not pulling you over because
they thought they saw something they're
pulling over because they saw something
yes so they're not they're not there's
not a question mark like i pulled brian
over i think i think you were going
a little too fast like i i have to know
that he was going over the speed limit
before i pulled them over
right not question usually for speeding
any car anybody will stop you but if a
motorcycle stops you
they had or and also vehicles have them
but not all of them but motorcycle cops
will have a radar
and they already watched you flying down
they have you on a radar they have you
the speed the speedometer everything
going down
and if you don't get a ticket when a
motorcycle officer pulls you over go buy
a lotto ticket because you're in luck oh
really there
yeah you're gonna get it if a motorcycle
cop pulls you over you're gonna get a
ticket correct
okay so so
when you pull somebody over in the car
or truck or come from work wherever the
kids
you're not really going to uncover any
real crime right
no there's not you're following a body
like in the trunk or anything or
anything like that somebody with a gun
that you pull over and they have a gun
or or they have you know stash anywhere
because i'm thinking that then you get
to the point where
the real violent crime is not somebody
you're going to pull over in a traffic
stop most likely
so that's almost like the undercurrent
of the streets
but then the drugs and
the human trafficking and all
the other stuff is a higher thing a
patrol officer is really not going to
probably run into much of that stuff or
is that more
detectives or people turning other
people in you know what i'm saying
because i know exactly
yeah so there's different ways in lapd
you got
you got a special unit just for almost
about everything right um
you have your your gang units you have
your special problems units
you have uh you know i don't even know
if you guys heard of sis but that's
different
but uh that's a special problem for the
guys that'll be undercover laying on the
floor pretending they're homeless yeah
you know they'll come out blasting but
these guys are bad asses i respect that
to them but
you also have like your gang and your
special problems you know their regular
police car
regular police car but they don't have
uh the lights but it is marked black and
white and they do have the lights inside
the
in this forward facing red those guys
are they call crime suppression units
they'll go out and find out if you're
driving a car
it's all beat up no plates tinted
windows
and you're in neighborhoods that are hot
what do i mean by hot you don't just go
because oh that's a minority living
there or anything
you just base yourself on all the crimes
that have happened like how many
shootings how many burglaries how many
robberies
so it's like a cluster that we put
together we're like hey this cluster is
going on here with all this
crap so then we send the officers there
and they'll start running cars
you know they go through a stop sign or
whatever and we pull them over and they
start taking off that's when you see a
lot of the pursuits and then you see
them throwing money or throwing guns
throwing weed cocaine crystal anything
boom out the window so when you pull
those guys over
you're like man these guys are one for
just about every single thing
from kidnap to murder to trafficking to
just name it right and that's the that's
the that's a crime suppression
type of uh traffic enforcement which is
a little different
has the body camera um is that how
i mean it sounds like a stupid question
but the body camera footage what's
what's what's the purpose of that so
that if you come up to me you're going
to see me right i'm not going to see you
right and then you're going to say like
some registration to go well i didn't do
anything
right you have all of it documented yeah
so you know for that
you know i came on the era before
cameras even before computers
but now with the camera and all that to
me it reminds me to be professional
and don't be [ __ ] anybody or
trying to slap people around or anything
like that
so it keeps me professional but it also
keeps an eye on the on the on the person
that i'm talking to
so if that person dictates you know as
an officer you just
our job is to watch your hands watch
what you're moving watch every single
move that you're doing because
we're trained to potentially you can
kill us so that's right
that's what that's for to document
anything that we might do to you
because you dictated that now it also it
can incriminate me if i am like a
i want to be gunslinger that i just want
to go gun home people
it'll be like hey dude you need to go
put yourself in the penalty box because
you're not good can can the job
change some change somebody to almost
not have respect for the communities
that it you know if you're
trying to do a good job and people are
not respectful of you a lot of people
disrespect the police
can do do guys that are or women that
are police officers
would they leave the force maybe like
after maybe 10 years they're like you
know what this isn't
i'm not doing what i really thought i
was going to do the community doesn't
respect us
it's dangerous and you know i might
i i do they leave i think what
you're right about that they become
desensitized um
one of the biggest things that i
actually
was always upset and arguing about is
that you have a lot of people in this
community
trying to become cops males and females
that work hard they try to stay out of
trouble
and uh yet they'll hire somebody from
tennessee
right they don't do a background
completely then finds out late we find
out later that he was
in the kkk or proud boys comes here
and you know i had a couple of officers
like i'm not going to mention their
names but
they said i came on the job to kill me a
wet back
or an n-word you know and i was like
what and then i turned around
and their theo was like a deputy chief
in the department so if i even went to
rat them out
i'm going to catch heat i mean that's
another level of topic but you know
i'm going to catch you i'm going to be
looking for a job later on because i
said hey this guy's no good
and then who am i to be throwing a rat
on that guy because he's like a made man
because he's
already yeah right now there's a lot of
those here and that's we're talking
about
you know they're what is that what
they're saying about uh
uh this idiot the last president we had
he said they asked them if there was any
uh
systemic racism that's the word i was
looking for
and he said no and i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me dude right
you know and it starts within you know i
i use no lapd
so lapd i could go in there and be like
that guy's a racist that guy's a racist
that guy's a racist
and they're in high rank positions and
they're
bringing it and they'll go and talk to
officers brainwash them
and then these other brainwashed
officers will try to bring watch more
more officers and he gets like that and
i always came in contact with people
like that and it was just so hard
for me to uh right to not i always
voiced my opinion and they didn't like
it oh well
and you saw that stuff firsthand though
i mean you saw those top officials
yes and they're still there right now
you know i can i mention one name
he's out yeah whatever his name is uh
matt blake he was a deputy chief and
long story short i guess he's a surfer
when he was going through the academy he
went surfing hit his head
and he was like pretty much almost
failing always all his uh
learning domains in the academy and he
hit his head
on the weekend he came back monday and
started ace and everything so something
happened with his head right
so he just kept going climbing climbing
climbing and
uh became a deputy chief he got it
against me for
a bunch of reasons he accused me of
being can i talk about that
yeah whatever you want yeah so so he uh
he accused me of uh
of being he's with his wife his ex-wife
and i'm like man
what the hell you know i was like but i
didn't know
this guy was actually losing his [ __ ]
mind as we were going
and he had you know tentacles in the
department so he sends me from one
division to another because i'm working
directly from him i think i remember
that yeah and then he
pretty much tried to [ __ ] me over so
many times and then he tried to demote
me and i like slammed my hands and he
got up real quick and was holding his
gun and i'm like oh my
god like and there was other office
there's one lady that's uh
she's the chief of santa san jose right
now and she was in that tail in there
and he's like you need to come down uh
well that time he was already a deputy
chief or commander blake you need to
come down
and i'm like dude i i just looked like
what you know like
like like a deer with headlights you
know it's like what the hell crazy story
yeah so that's one of the things that
made me just like
let me get the hell out of here but
that's a dangerous person to be
i mean once a once a guy gets or
a person gets on the force do they um
evaluate them like maybe after five
years or like with your driver's license
you have to go every once in a while get
renewed
or you're just in you're in you're in
you're in you're in you're in
and it's up to you to police yourself to
make sure you don't get in trouble
uh you do they do give you classes on
how to deal with whatever issues are
coming up
but like you said like physically they
do have a
psychologist or psychiatrist ready if
you want to go talk but
it's not it's not forced upon you to say
hey you need to go over here and talk to
you so
if somebody if somebody that's listening
is in a neighborhood where they think
maybe a house
might be something might be happening
there or
some people might be doing some shady
stuff
it would you recommend that they call
the police to say
there's some you know mysterious
activity on my street these people come
out late hours and they're doing this
you know or is it better just to mind
your own business you know what
it depends what your quality of life how
you want to live
if you don't they find out that you did
it right so one of the
the thing for that will be you should
just we mentioned this get to know your
police department your division where
you live
go inside and talk to your senior lead
officer who's a guy that will
have a lot of officers working and they
have yes he's got the knowledge of who
to go talk to
and make that happen so and you're going
to fill out a paper saying you want to
remain anonymous
a matter of fact if i'm the senior
leader you talk to me i don't even want
your name i want to know your address
the address of the individual okay and
so the description and what they're
doing in the hours
so so if somebody's following a
complaint you don't really have to give
your name
no not at all okay you ought to be that
but also i think that that
that a lot of stuff goes on and people
turned a blind eye but
what they're really doing is destroying
the community and
it's not i don't think you're really
ratting i just think it's
if some bad activity is on your street
it's going to grow it's not going to get
it's not going to go away right like
there was some i lived around some
people that were bad every one time i
was in a hotel in the next room they
were wayne
they're weighing drugs
like i could hear them you know the time
of the scale and bring this over here
and stuff like that
wow
you know what i was jeremy horvath
what tell so so what is the what is the
fun the police mean
because i don't think most do you know
what the fun the police means well i
think they
what it really means i i believe it's
it's that uh
lower what the taxpayers pay to to keep
the police going
correct that's what they're after they
don't want to give as much taxpayer
money
to aid the police department right
[ __ ] bernie sanders
you know you're absolutely right hey one
of the one of the things that i
feel like one of the things that you
have to understand is if you defund the
police
i'll tell you another i mean i got a
bunch of stories but one of them i was
eating on
there's a restaurant on uh vermont and
eighth street
is a thai place it's got a big old
window right and i'm just sitting down
to eat and i turn around
and i see this um three gangbangers hit
up the other gangbanger
and they stab them just but as soon as i
turned my head i looked
they stabbed them must have stabbed them
at least 28 times oh my gosh
and then they saw me in my partner and
they're like holy [ __ ] they took off
that guy ran across the street the guy
that got stabbed across the street
and he says sir never in my [ __ ] life
i've ever been so glad to see a police
officer
and he collapsed but because this guy
saw us
they they were they were making his way
up they were just hitting up on their
chest and stomach
they were making his way up to his neck
and they didn't do it because we
got him but unfortunately i mean
fortunately they didn't they didn't stop
him on any uh
vital areas and the guy lived wow you
know and he actually changes uh
his life around and it was kind of kind
of nice to see somebody that changed his
life and
he would come around the station and
said man if it wasn't for you guys
i would have been dead so if you're
talking about defunding the police be
careful what you wish for
because [ __ ] might happen to you and
you'll be like damn where are they now
so the funding the police would because
already i think every police force
is understaffed yes i think the lapd
could use a thousand more officers and
but nobody wants to
nobody wants to be a police officer
right right they don't i got up
you know no of course but i'm saying
like if nobody wants to be a police
officer
that's that's a huge problem yeah and if
i because you you crime's not going to
go away
and even in the area that i live
remember i sent you that picture yes
everybody's got these ring cameras they
get packages stolen and they got people
that
roll up on their porches and dangerous
steal stuff from
but none of them take any action like
they stand i'd fire
man listen i'd take a gun and fire over
their heads
i bet they don't come back but these
guys just watch it on the video camera
and then post it to the neighbor next
door app and they don't do [ __ ] about it
right yeah i'm ignorant in the defunding
to police as
how that would help anybody because if
you're having a problem with your police
department it probably means it's
because
it's not at the level it needs to be and
the only way it could be at the level
you want to be
is to fund them more that would make
sense to me i don't know if that makes
sense to you
you know i think part of the the funding
of police comes from people that are
angry at cops
yeah that are [ __ ] things up you know
and go back to systemic racism going in
there
and you're hiring people not from the
community i mean here in california we
got over 40 million people we should be
picking people that are police officers
within this state
right i don't know why we're going some
other places they don't even
like any other people so i mean just get
it get it done over here
and then also when you get caught if i
if if an officer gets gets uh caught
doing some criminal stuff
hang them out to dry [ __ ] them yeah you
know if you're doing something stupid
you're going to try to taint all the
other officers
you know so so put the [ __ ] out to dry
and i think when they're
talking about defunding the police is
because most of the money
aside of the salaries that are paid for
the officers
is go it goes to settling lawsuits
and it's just incredible wow wow a part
we wouldn't know about right yeah so
that should be
you know when you talk about the funding
i think officers there should be people
in place
to be saying i would love for that to
happen uh deputy chief you're getting
paid 250
000 you're a racist get the [ __ ] out of
here let's bring in somebody else that
will do a better job
and that will have a better leadership
and teach these cops that
you know what go out there and do your
job but don't go on trying to beat
people don't go on trying to do
something that's dumb that's going to
create
you know this big old massive walks that
we saw you know and people just
protesting because they're tired
and they don't want to take it anymore
so that that that will go us
deep on the police you know that's what
i okay
let me ask you um
what is the job of the sheriff's
department
because if you have the police
department then you have the sheriff
remember sheriff john when you were
little
of course channeled on channel 11. and
all he did was sing songs
so what you know it wasn't lapd sheriff
john
it wasn't a police officer john the show
sheriff john so already andy griffith he
was the sheriff
you you almost think that i want to
disparage sheriffs
but in the deputy dog was a sheriff
you know what i mean like you know
deputy dog wasn't lapd deputy dog
the bachelorette [ __ ] starfish i mean
you know
what authority do they have okay well
first of all i have great respect for
the sheriffs
thanks a lot well i was just shot
[ __ ] through
two cars no i'll be there with you
right you're the defunded sheriff's guy
i don't know
well i think the job that they do is at
this on the cities that
do not have police departments and they
also come in and actually help
small police departments like you know i
remember arcadia had a
double homicide a few months ago and
they don't have the resources
so shares will come in and they'll take
over for that
for that scene the homicide scene and
then they'll build
that city for their services i did not
know that my god i did not know i swear
okay so they're almost like uh so does
arcadia have their own police
i believe arcadia does and there's also
there's a part that's unincorporated
that belongs the shares patrol that
you know it seems crazy to me that in
that there wouldn't be just almost like
full coverage
where you're you're protected everywhere
and that you wouldn't have to like farm
out the sheriffs to come in
right and that you know you would be
under one
especially in this part of the country
you would think that would never be the
case all right
you know they have a boring [ __ ]
they have they have a
um there you go get in there daddy was a
police department
and they because the lawsuits they lost
all their money and the shares came in
and took over
and um you know i did say i have great
respect
for the sheriffs but they're you know i
call them they're like stomachs you know
everything they touch it turn into [ __ ]
because you know mayweather was not that
bad now you go see their crime
and he's like to [ __ ] you know uh
there's other cities that they want to
come in and take over like small other
departments like you know
there was talks about alhambra monterey
park montebello
and the people they're like no we don't
want you guys there because you guys
first of all they're not lapd they're
not no no they're regular they're
montevallo pd
alhambra pd they're good good coppers
there you call them they come up real
quick they take care of business
and you know it's been my experience
personal experience where
the sheriffs are patrolling let's say
maywood
and they don't have not even one sheriff
patrolling
in maywood that [ __ ] has to come from
the marina
code 3 meaning lights and siren get his
ass all the way over there to answer a
radio
call so can you imagine if you live in a
place and you got to call the sheriff
you know again no pun intended but [ __ ]
you got to call it what it is
wow that's half an hour till he gets
there or whatever it's like yeah you
might
be dead yeah there's nobody there's
nobody else to call right
there's no no uh adt
i mean you could call you could get your
get yourself a uh security team be like
you said
what what about adt or the the the the
[ __ ] mcgruff for the crime dog game
which one which one's here what cars are
his my breath that's right
but he had him for dare or something oh
yeah he was derrick
mcgrath the lion and mcgruff
so so if you hire a a private security
like
where i live and they drive around [ __ ]
cars smile like barrels and [ __ ] you
know they don't
they don't have any authority what does
that guy have on them i i can go
pepper spray right
so so after that guy shits on himself he
sees somebody
robbing a house and he drives up
what what does uh like like everybody
pays
oh god [ __ ] puts it in reverse uh so so
let's say a neighborhood is pain
it is that is that a scam like if you
have
i don't want to let's say you have uh
horvath security
and and and you you sign up for a month
maybe 250 and they pass by your house
13 times a night and
you feel safer because you have are they
effective what are they doing
you know again i think talking to
criminals you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah i get
yeah because you know the lapd is not
going to be there
so the people where i or where anybody
lives if you see
a guy driving around he puts his light
you know like you know you need
oh who's there you know
but does he have any legal authority
yeah because i always thought he was
there to call you
right right as a security guard pretty
much you have to be there just to be
highly visible
to deter whatever it is but think you
know technically you can't do [ __ ]
you don't you can't do anything there at
all so
but the one thing that i was going to
get into is you know
i interviewed so many uh career
criminals
a couple things they tell you and if
they're listening hopefully
they get they they can vouch it'll be uh
you know i talk to the criminal they'll
say like you know what if i walk around
and i see a security guard i see a
camera or even this
the the you know little things that it
says adt or whatever
he says i go to the next house because
that carries
an enhancement if i get booked okay so
they'll look for the it's like a broken
window concept
they'll be like hey nobody says [ __ ]
over there they don't have anything on
the left
but if i go to the right they even have
this [ __ ] security guard with peace
things all around
right but you know that's that's enough
for me to look somewhere else because
they're still there and they'll make a
nuisance for me they'll down i want one
so
it'll be an additional call that's going
to be generated so i run i'd rather go
to the place that nobody calls
so they do work at some level at some
level just a
visibility yeah it's like having a dog
at the house he's a whistleblower kind
of guy now if somebody wants to like you
know
take you out or whatever he's just going
to be another victim
oh really that's another hardcore thing
so it depends who you are what you have
you want to get the right what a person
what does that guy have in his car
does he have a radio you know maybe a
can with a [ __ ] string
[Applause]
he's he's got a radio to his dispatch
which would be another person on the
other hand but
they had no jack in the box
can i help you yeah hey uh uh manuel oh
hang on it's like i'm taking somebody
call me at five minutes so yeah uh but
but
he doesn't have a gun he probably has
some candidates you have a gun
but but do you have to if i'm paying
those 250 a month or whatever
that you're paying you want to demand
that you see that you want to demand
that you see a guard card
and you want to demand to see if he's
got a gun and does he have a gun card
because you want to have that oh i
stopped so many guards like the ones
you're mentioning
that have like a fake gun just to deter
and i'm like dude if you get a real
criminal that gun's going to get you
killed
you know because you have that you're
bringing that to the party and you
better step up
he's a freeze wow wow wow that's right
but but some but somebody wow wow but
somebody but somebody who's out there
who's like a real criminal like somebody
like like my uncle was a real criminal
like that dude could you know he worked
around the nights he could slide in and
out he was just
you know he was good at going unseen but
he was stealing [ __ ]
a little bit of drugs and all that [ __ ]
but he knew his way around
the system he worked in a car wash so it
wasn't something that you had to
you know be there every day and all that
stuff but he was he
every day that he got up he thought
criminally he didn't think
in terms of like you know how can i get
through this beautiful day he's like
where can i [ __ ] somebody over what can
i get some money what can i crazy
steal something off somebody's porch or
some [ __ ] like people stealing
packages from off of people's porches
right right
those are opportunistic type of uh you
know crimes you see a
box and [ __ ] just stop and run
and get out something like you know your
uncle people like that
those are the ones that you want to be
careful but those are the ones that will
tell you
don't look in that they'll scope a house
before they go hit it they'll come in a
day before three days before
they'll check it out and if they see
something they don't like like a camera
right a big old sign whatever it is
all that stuff works the camera or adt
even yeah you're
put all that stuff out and uh don't look
for the house that's that's
minimal they don't want to mess with why
do people still leave valuable [ __ ] on
the in their car when somebody walks by
or they see like a computer or some
headphones
they break in and take them right yeah i
mean i could tell you because they're
stupid
you know
i mean in the neighbor next door
somebody says oh be careful because
there's a guy going around breaking into
cars
i like computer taking my headphones and
some shoes are like you're [ __ ]
leaving them in the open
yeah right you're drawing that guy to my
neighborhood and in some instances
they even leave their car unlocked so
they just open it up and take everything
because this and some of them will be
like oh i didn't want them breaking my
my my glass my window i'm like whoa
for real yeah they're like i'd rather
have them just walk in and just get the
stuff what can people do
to their own house and car to make
themselves safer to feel safer
should women carry you know they told
women to put the keys between their
fingers
ah that's hand hand that's already done
come on you're dead
a guy or anybody in somebody that's
going to attack anybody
is is not going to go are your keys
between your fingers because if they are
i'll get the [ __ ] out of here
you know how they you know right but
that's
yeah that's monsters like fighting a
monster right i think the biggest thing
if you could have would be like maybe
pepper spray yeah right
and learn how to practice how to how to
you know like you go you get a gun you
got to practice how to shoot that's your
best friend
i got some in the car right now we go
over there and me and victor will shoot
it at you yeah
i i want to see what it feels like
just practice and you'll see you see
it's really effective i mean i sprayed a
lot of people
because yeah that's a great story no
it works no because it you know you
can't see
right and it puts you in a you know
pepper spray like if you're a regular
person you spray somebody even a female
too
gives you a chance to get away that's
one of the biggest things yeah you know
we've gone as far as talking to like i
was dating a girl from mexico and she
like hot food so i would put some on the
tip of my head again she loved it
they didn't even make her i didn't make
her cry or anything really like i don't
know what to put out
i don't know what kind of soapy music
but i like it that's called a keeper i'm
writing about
yarn well thanks for coming in amazing i
mean i learned a ton of screwdriver
yeah yeah it's so everybody be safe yeah
please
and one last thing if you don't imagine
if
my daughter was driving and someone was
going to pull her over and she didn't
trust that it was a real cop what should
she do
okay sorry one of the things just make
sure that the light is red
that she's getting pulled over that time
or day and where she's getting pulled
over
you know hopefully is where it's a big
city the other one if you're not safe
down 9-1-1 you know then call you
but first down 9-1-1 says hey i'm
getting pulled over i don't recognize
this guy's a regular police officer can
you let me know
usually a police officer if i'm gonna
pull somebody over
i'm gonna get over the radio and say my
location
in the license plate of the vehicle i'm
being pulled over so
if your daughter generates a call says
uh yes ma'am that guy is a real police
officer he's pulling you over okay thank
you and that way she'll feel at ease
and that'll come in within maybe two
minutes yeah
at that long because that's what i'm
thinking if she doesn't pull over and
and the cop wants her to pull over
is there something that like the cop
would say that we would know it's a cop
i mean i don't know
to make her pull over because i wouldn't
want her to pull over because he's like
i'm a real cop and then you pull over i
mean she just is it okay
would a is a cop has does he have
patience you know why you're driving
making a lot of
patience dr following someone for like
two minutes while you figure it out go
to a gas station and pull into a
place that's well lit like a 7-eleven a
gas station you could do that somewhere
instead of pulling over in some
neighborhood yeah yeah exactly that's
what i'm saying
you know what and i think the officer 99
of the times will understand like hey
it's a single lady
and she wasn't feeling that you know
they'll see they'll they'll release it
and then if she's not driving
erratically obviously you know what
they'll get on the
on the on the pa system and say hey pull
over pull over
so police officers not trying to pull
you over in the middle of nowhere
right yeah yeah be worried about that if
you especially like you
coming from vegas or something like that
yeah you got to watch that
yeah because you guys get it right if
it's a dark place you don't understand
something's going to go it will even
guide you to tell you to keep going to
the next block or we'll see like us
we don't want to get [ __ ] alleged that
we did something wrong
well thank you so much for being here
what all right that's good amazing guest
right well thanks victor thank you thank
you for having me thank you thank you
very much
you